passer à la fois c'était à deux trois
bons entre temps j'ai eu comme un
colosse apte à hulk au vide
ouais c'est pour ça que j'étais pas trop
écrit je n'étais pas une semaine un peu
dur un dur bazire a conclu sa non mais
en fait c'est la double peine cantal
coville était papa parce que la petite
peut pas aller à la crèche donc déjà tu
es fatigué et en plus elle la petite est
là toute la journée donc c'est la double
peine tant à genoux sur la corrida mais
non en allemand ça les gpu de gros
symptômes c'est juste très fatigué tiru
mais j'ai une migraine chiante
mais bon ça j'en ai déjà sans le comique
donc je ne sais pas vraiment s'il
convient ou pas quoi agiter testé
positif car ma mère aussi à rendre
démente et à marcher sur le candidat
était négatif de fois
du coup elle a fait comme moi c'est à
dire par diana elle l'a eu et moi j'ai
pas eu de symptômes j'ai pu pas fait de
tests en même temps mais nous on est
obligé par rapport à la crèche parce que
si elle est positive sur une semaine
après mois la petite peut pas aller à la
crèche encore par rapport à l'alpha
chinois huawei
alalala punk sommes donc ok du coup on
connaît maintenant le maillon fort de ta
famille est-ce que tu as eu un dodo
non je n'ai jamais été en doute mais
c'est une confirmation de ce qu'on de
compenser tous savent que le match
pendant que je mettais les calmes parce
qu'ils étaient en retard est parti et du
coup écoute première partie partie on a
raté 40 secondes de match
est ce que ce seront les 40 secondes
décisive mathieu c'est la question qu'on
se pose on espère ou pas non alors lui
dit qu'ils me dis que j'ai pu atteindre
100 automatique oui mais si j'étais
asymptomatiques c'est que j'ai marché
sur les symptômes aussi quoi une fine et
c'est la même chose mais n'avait pas
vraiment parce que c'était négatif tu
t'es pas contagieux ah oui moi je sais
pas si j'ai été contagieux mais un
symptôme atik tu peux être contagieuse
qui peut être croit d'ailleurs
oui c'est pas enfin bon elle a été
négatif de fournes j'ai pas compris
ah oui mais non mais tu sais les
maladies a pas tous les gens qui peuvent
aller les virus ne peuvent pas rentrer
dans toutes les personnes en fait les
personnes qui attraperont jamais une
maladie en fait c'est tu parles des
virus non mais de les aider
solide en europe de l'est en russie tu
sais ta femme et la fille ça marche pas
tout le train ouais mais europe de l'est
quand même elle a eu deux jours d'arrêt
de travail puisque c'est à l'époque on
ne savait pas que c'était locaux vides
donc l aller bosser avec le colis de ma
femme ses collègues l'ont lui aussi du
couffin certains c'est quoi c'est une
jeune âge d'or f3 mais il ya des trucs
chelous une dame en e2 etc et bien
africa j'avoue que j'ai pas compris
l'onu déjà vraiment c'est un peu bizarre
s'est passé f-35 a pris si si ça existe
pour s'être cassée si c'est du jamais vu
quasiment n'ont cette fois pas j'ai des
arguments
oui c'est pas très souple normalement
mais il n'a pas l'air si mal la baie st
mais le jeu quoi dams et 7
il veut faire des cahiers à 3 qui est
prend b2 avec une torrent ses 8 ans
toujours dans le même neige d'or faut
faire gaffe à la casse des 5 1 tonnes
avait fait je crois j'avais commenté le
plusieurs parties sur ce thème dans la
partie de maxime brèthes on avait fait
masse des partis avec la case des cinq
noyés image aussi dans les parties
pédagogique vous en avez vu donc demain
c'est pour pouvoir sortir le fouet fin
des cinq c'est bien je vous prends elle
veut sans doute reprendre de b donc là
en fait il faut savoir que ce vent au
roi en un an
une tour en b1 ça peut être hyper solide
lui plaire ça mais en fait 2 dans
l'autre jour ils étaient hyper mal parti
dans son match donc il faut voir s'il
rentre mieux dans le match
la narco balaÿ l'art de tempête rentrer
en tout cas dans l'ouverture là les
premières minutes
c'est mieux que la nano pourrait donc
tourbeux 8 qui veut jules roy à 1 et
défend il veut faire fou si elle est
encore plus solide
c'est peut-être un peu trop solide la
non mathieu jeux repas de tactique je
comprends 14.4 sa défense rouge et cela
choquait prix car ça peut être un thème
il leur faut prendre un set qui est
français 3 et chaque intermédiaire ça
peut être cette jolie petite maison de
marché apple
enfin je crois pas d'ailleurs est ce que
ça marche vraiment pas annonçant ne pas
alors qu'elle prend 1,4 frange est sain
il remarqué pranger 5 c3 dans ce domaine
j'ai fait du besoin avec mazet pendant
une heure et alors il a un peu jeune âge
il fait combien réseau mais non en fait
c'est pas le plus heureux
on a fait le 1 contre 1 ouais je sais
mais il fait combien du corps en un
contre un ce que c'est le même jeu
finalement non ben on sait que trois
minutes mais c'est moi je préfère le 5
minutes soit cinq minutes il ya tu vois
que les la fin les exos sont juste super
show ces qui font aussi la 3e minute
c'est rarement des trucs dur c'est juste
beaucoup de réflexes et non on n'était
pas bon j'étais intelligent ou pas hein
tu le déchirent ou pas il commence moi
j'avais fait du peu de leur acheter
pendant le confinement
j'en ai fait pas mal je te monte
49 en cinq minutes où je sais pas si
j'ai fait cinquante et une fois sur 49
deux fois il va y trouve les matins elle
pas tous et du coup c'était marrant ça
gueulait de partout on a bien rigolé
commence à coller deux parties et des
spectateurs et tous et vous nous nous
engueuler j'aimerais bon ben j'ai vu ma
zone on a mis les gestes barrière mais
là tu as raison tu as plus un jet de
barrières avec maso je crois tu adores
locaux vides web os pour lui mais
normalement la wii il est utile de fac
on l'a vu en fait toi il peut pas te le
passé toi tu veux pas lui passer
en théorie on n'a pas le droit mais où
on s'est vus non mais l'image a relaté
enfin que tu es le droit ou pas de toute
façon le risque il est ou signaler au
gouvernement indirects non maintenant et
puis il ya peu de risques parce que je
sais que les oui baril serait dingue
dinars côté ni de l'autre en fait parce
qu'il peut pas te le passé tu peux pas
du passé donc voilà ils peuvent u11 il
peut pas jeter prend des cinq pions
prends parce que son tour b si ça prend
c'est qu'il ya plutôt pro d2 a il a dû
oublier ça bon mais faut des buts c'est
bien joué dans sweet way donc du coup
c'était marrant il ya des demandes et
quand même je compte maso un moment on a
rigolé et alors qu'ils gagnent maso mais
il est bien fait défaut il fait 3 heures
donc l'autre à boîte derrière tu peux
avoir mon meilleur score de la journée
j'ai dû faire 38 en trois minutes c'est
beaucoup et sinon on tournait autour de
34 mais ouais il je crois sans record
c'était 13 projets exagère il fait des
fois il joue trop vite ou il m'explique
je me suis fait engueuler se disant ma
souris étaient trop rapides
donc ils ont du show avec des montées
ils m'ont fait changer les paramètres de
la souris pour pouvoir e s qui peuvent
essayer d'amener un fou en a cinq
il faut des huit dames b ça marche dans
le bessin c'est un ami des jeux caïds et
5 fu des 8
je commence à bien aimer la nature afin
que cette bien sûr même
et en fait les blancs comme donc dans
cette attaque anglaise idc d'attaquer le
roi mais les ans on a quand même là mais
sont en fait je pense que même dans l'
attaque anglaise sans justice c'est de
défendre un nom mais ça me fait penser
un peu aguerris qui joue un répertoire
hyper offensif mais sans être offensif
il laisse faire ces trois kékem son idée
c'est juste b3 et après je cueille des
cinq mois je pense qu'ils y qui couvre
avec le phocéen et couvre les cases
maintenant fait ils peuvent choquer et
des 5 pour pouvoir prendre la tour il
veut menacer de vie c'est fait il ajout
stratégique mais très souvent ces
structures mais derrière c'est une
structure de calage des boues dans
beaucoup de neige d'or c'est hyper
stratégique mais là il veut aussi dû
bouffer des dames non hockey et on prend
des 6 i l faut s est pas tant va la
sortir la dame c'est pas possible des
jacaré les dessins qui peut pas aider
qui va vous chez le roi
ouais parce que si trois cavaliers de
cet échec
nos villages hongrois et fuite je pense
ouais ouais je suit pas sûr qu'ils
aillent en fuite parce qu'avec fuite il
est dans le viseur de la dame tudor y
aura peut-être un f4 un jour mais af447
peut être vraiment un coût avantageux c3
le foot est ainsi peu bougé tu peux
sauver la dame par un simple coup de
fouet pour la maintenance et un risque
voilà donc finalement ils jouent pas ce
plan ce donc il veut juste à 4 c'est
hyper logique 1 1 et 1 4 est ce que ça
fait vraiment quelque chose ça commence
un peu à tourner mais ce donc avait été
hyper impressionnant son début de match
puis mauvais puis voilà lui c'était
enfin mauvais dans le sens il est
vraiment et il le fait il avait lâché
surtout trop facile or sous c'est pas si
les gens se rendent compte à quel point
il est fort en fait il est juste
tellement insupportable qu'on le déteste
j'ai dit oui à sa façon de jouer mais en
fait il est vraiment super fort alors en
960 ce qu'il avait mis à carson c'était
hyper hyper impressionnant
monde de 964 depuis déjà deux ans donc
non c'est un très bon joueur qui est
juste peur de perdre assez rédhibitoire
que je faisais un trajet simple mais
toujours pas menacé sur la fourche
atteint donc très bien joué 4 maintenant
le fonds va pour un peu active et le 960
ce qu'on appelle les échecs fischer
c'est quand vous mettez les pièces en
début de partie sur des cases aléatoire
est ce n900 pas 300 oui c'est que si 1
960 possibilités ça l'adil 959 et donc
est une erreur non non c'est jusqu'à
position de départ il ne l'a compte pas
et ont validé ces qui envoya il ya comme
une règle il faut que les tour ce de
part et d'autre des rois pour pouvoir
qu'il ya une sorte de rock et c'est
assez marrant quand j'ai fait le
championnat d'europe ou veille à bâtir
le tournoi à reykjavik et la zone euro
pour y avait un ton et un style rigolo
un tapis derrière convient belge était
très bien parti après j'ai perdu une
potion c'est le bon pote il
je m'étais fait arnaquer après je crois
j'ai fait trois défaites de suite
j'adore et là la réponse devra aussi à
la question est ce que tu penses que
pedro et j'ai regardé les parties j'ai
regardé les parties à tours à huit vous
prend y'a pas un truc sympa fou g5
hummels amadou même c'est pas maintenant
on prend ces trois cantons où la dame 1
et est ce qu il ya deux ou là on n'est
pas fous là ça va là ça tient ouais ça
tient mais après avec des passes de ça
devait pas tous bien ré pas sur un
taille haie il n'a pas été prise et il y
avait des français de moins il fallait
gagner écrit blanc bon par contre si ça
joue comme ça tout le match je vous
annonce qu'on va se régaler ouais je
sais plus quoi dire là ce qui est en
train de se passer mathieu c'est même la
gagner encore une fois ci menace f4
hyper bien jouer d'un f4 avec 2 secondes
il a réussi à jouer avec 0
on a la chance de ne pas être tombé fou
et quatre non au 6e tour prend aussi
c'est le cocktail budget de maintenance
le plus chic leur ouais ça doit faire
nul mathieu aurait un meilleur appât nul
dans la partie mais j'ai changé je vous
prends g6 à non ils jouent pour le gars
fait changer coup il va la perdre ou pas
mais away non je crois qu'il va la
perdre
pour ces deux tours dans mes couilles
herald vient comme ça il n'y a pas de
dépression 804 vite il va vraiment la
perte a raison ah non non il va la tenir
avec va retenir mathieu et je fais
forteresse ouais c'est que des partis
comme ça ça valait le coup c'est
terrible et tanger ça il a échangé à
brive
je leur pose est allé nulle un ouais il
ya une rage intérieure
il ya une règle et c'est à ce moment
c'est que les faits et je les montre à
des joueurs assez bons il y en a pas mal
qui connaissent pas comment faire nul
avec deux pions connecte facile il faut
connaître le set up qui est pas dû à 39
de menaces
je les mêmes faits en master master
hightech la masse il moi je me suis pris
à partie le coup c'est un choix du monde
jeunes jusqu'en être en fait tu connais
c'est facile oui c'est ça ouais mais
ouais c'est tu peux ne pas connaître un
bon montreux alors à tous niveaux c'est
simple à faire quand tu connais je veux
être mille si tu connais tu connais un
voilage annoncé nulle complètement à la
tour non désolé les catéchètes on attend
les 50 kw c'est un peu ça va d'un gros
c'était quoi c'est duda bien pixo le aux
playes puis
ma vie était malade et donc se gagne en
puissance calme et à la défendre
évidemment pour proposer le bon gars
super fois un parti plus que quatre
heures de plus 3h50 de jeu en fait ça
dépend et c'est que des partis comme ça
ça va être sympa alors là il le troll il
joue là petrov que doit jouer tout le
temps normalement une petite surprise
nous à la maison l'autre jour mais bon
il se faisait dominer dans toutes les
ouvertures et se faisait dominer mais
après il était juste plus forts dans des
parties très rapide auquel et de céline
à la mode
je prends un petit plus qui a fait ça
tout âge je trouve qu'il n'a pas
progressé depuis
depuis un an un an deux ans là non et
moi je me suis fait la même remarque
mais juste en fait j'arrive et son halo
il a augmenté
ouais mais en fait tu sais pourquoi on a
cette impression
ben parce que je toujours les mêmes
merde bah c'est ça ouais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il a essayé de step up
séraphine joue toujours les mêmes
ouverture ans même s'ils progressent un
peu dans le niveau de jeu toute façon
c'est pas en jouant des ouvertures comme
ça que tu deviens top 5 mondial
ça te fait pas penser ce que vlad et
d'histoire tenir pas si c'est la même
chose parce que je sais pas si tu rates
ingénierie et enfin commencé avant-hier
à redire et il a dit que moquer c'est
vrai ce que tu as dit qu'il était moins
bien entouré
mais après c'est à toi un moment tu te
bouger le cul comme ne pas continuer a
ajouté mr ouai je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord et pour moi c'est un peu le
même ils ont pas le même talent mais ils
sont tous les deux très talentueux je
t'avais dis je la veux je pour ça que
j'avais fait venir un pronostic dans
notre équipe
le connais qu'un duda savent habitat
dense atteint
ouais mais bon vous normand sabots aller
vite si tu fais pas le travail pour
aller au top mondial ça peut aller aussi
vite que tu veux tu y arriveras jamais
un mais je pense je pense en fait que
pour duda c'est déjà quasi fin de
carrière en fait
et oui train de deuil là il est 27,65 je
crois non mais je veux dire c'est bien
il a battu car arsène et tout ça mais je
veux dire en fait si tu change pas de
manière d'être et de mentalité en fait
tasser fini en fait il est 53 43 élèves
les 27 99 108 27 74 ans rapide 19e
mondiale ça va mais ouais mais gers ici
prend pas c'est qu'il agit là il a 22
ans 2 1 à ses 10 c'est terrible de dire
c'est fini ce n'est qu'à 22 que comme
artemis d'ailleurs ouais mais je suis
désolé en fait si tu fais tu met pas les
ingrédients pour pour faire le job
on va dire qu'il joue 15e mondial de 15
à 8 en fait c'est en fait ils var est il
peut plus progresser la cie fait pas le
job
ouais c'est ça mais non mais je propose
juste d'accord c'est une fois qu'ils se
bougent le cul et moi j'aime bien son
entraîneur la mi temps c'est un pote
mais pour moi il est trop limitative il
faut arriver le quasi mme mills n 1
vlad la nation baky papa qui pourra pas
le débaucher mais je cite juste des gens
qui pourraient le après est ce que ça
vaut le coup de passer par des mains de
d'anciens genre tout mac os
kouzmine beliatski qu'ils ont tous un
moment apporté quelque chose mais après
un général qui prend quelqu'un juste
pour la théorie
mais de voir un peu ce que c'est que les
essais les échecs un peu haut niveau un
peu à l'ancienne
je pense cela dit les un peu sale
avantage de pouvoir faire des deux
d'ailleurs case in d'adobe je pense
aussi anne aussi etienne est très
classique mais tient aussi bas de façon
les meilleurs en fait ils font les deux
du coup mais ouais et pourrait prendre
aussi un eliana faut des joueurs comme
ça il ya neuf je sais pas s'ils ont déjà
seconde en mai il y en a peut être pas
mal aussi
il ya neuf si la seconde et les filles
les soeurs un zouk nous sommes sûr mais
je sais qu'il n'est pas si bon en fait
parce que il a travaillé avec des
joueurs de nuit ce petit jeu le bonus
entraîné il a fait des stages du moins
avec certains d'aujourd'hui est un bon
musulman que c'est un peu à l'arraché
toi mais non mais s'ils s'y fait pas ce
travail là c'est triste à dire mais en
fait si à un moment donné tu le fais pas
en fait tu peux jouer aussi bien que tu
le souhaites tu arrives pas on peut
prendre l'exemple de bobby fischer qui
était le plus grand joueur peut-être de
l'histoire machin moment donné il a fait
un travail tout bobby fischer qu'ils
étaient sans ce travail là il n'aurait
jamais à régler ses problèmes
j'ai passé on en a parlé parce que j'en
ai parlé dans le chat jusque là vu tes y
avait une vidéo sur wii qui a été sorti
par nielsen et gustafsson de ce qu'ils
préfèrent enfin les champions du monde
sont de leurs avis et j'ai trouvé ça
assez instructif que le journal parlé
avec maso qui pour lui dit numéro un
c'est fisher et c'était en fait ça
dépend ce que tu comptes
c'est ça qui est intéressant parce qu'au
niveau longévité il a eu un petit trou
il n'a pas joué il a arrêté tout de
suite et eux ils ont mis k sport enfin
un carlson en deux
fischer hélas caire en quatre j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant classement je ne
sais pas si j'aurais fait ça on est donc
probablement non
je pense pas que j'aurais fait ça non
plus mais l'argument c'est que tu peux
pas m car c'est l'an 1 pour l'instant
c'est sa carrière n'est pas finie et les
deux derniers matches il n'a pas non
plus été complètement rayonnant mais la
question c'est est-ce que fisher tout de
même pour tout de suite
en fait non mais j'ai l'impression que
tu peux pas fâché par la défaite mais
fisher aussi avant dans le sens où il
dit c'est le seul qui a réussi seul face
à tous en fait oui oui il a réalisé en
fait c'est irréaliste c'est impossible
en fait mais en fait le truc c'est que
tu as plusieurs trucs à prendre en
compte dans la longévité
le talent pur bas lorsque on a
l'impression mais quand tu lui dis
talons cure qui met en perspective la
les générations par exemple morphy pis
de riz sont peut-être au-dessus en fait
on n'en sait rien mais là le gaf qu'ils
ont mis sur les autres est tellement
dingue
pourquoi pas peut-être que c'est les
plus gros talent pur
c'est hyper dur dur
après l'eau j'écoute aussi ce qu'a dit
plein de surfer de seief qui la remarque
le niveau était pas terrible
tu apprends des autres c'est pas les
mêmes échecs certes mais on peut en plus
je suis sûr que aller qui n'y reviens
avec les connaissances si tu enlèves
vraiment la théorie théorie pure mais
revient avec son niveau de jeu et ses
connaissances du milieu de jeu final et
c'est l'époque aujourd'hui les pmi je
dis tout de suite me suis même tu peux
même aller plus loin tu dis un ali keane
qui n'est maintenant qu'à prend
exactement la même façon le fait de c
est fou n'importe qui je pense qu'il est
meilleur que les deux sièges non mais
largement même pas de fédérer faire
monter le monde estime quand j'ai vu
c'est un autre jour comme une zone
c'est un jockey mais il joue bien et
machin mais bon après tu peux être bon
joueur d'échecs et être un peu stupide
en dehors après faut ce qu'il dit ça
pour faire le buzz je suis pas sûr que
non utilisés pour faire le buzz vue qui
fait zéro base ça pose aussi des
questions quoi sur ses pas juste avec
moi qui l'avais dit ça c'est juste
d'entendre dans votre live après ouais
c'est sûrement il est sûrement dit ça en
russe
ben parce qu'ils font une espèce de
chaînes en russie là qui m'a
pas du tout par ailleurs là le truc de
journalistes parce qu'ils n'expliquent
et de l'ebita fouet
l'ex président de la fédération russe
des échecs qui veut revenir musulmans
politique sage et bien une interview de
la tarte tatin ouais mais du coup ils
ont un budget pharaonique et il plafonne
à 7,8 milles vu par vidéo sur youtube
quoi j'ai pardonné mois cinquante mille
euros par mois on verra mais c'est
terrible ouais mais j'ai envie de me
mettre un petit bémol à ce que tu dis
c'est que toi tu as déjà la communauté
derrière là le mec il arrive
intervenants heures il sort des vidéos
c'est si je sais pas si ces six hommes
de vue que si tu as autant d'argent vu
qu'il est rappelé que des invités invite
des gens qui ont une communauté enfin
enfin enfin tu vas rester là mais ça
c'est un truc qui comprennent pas parce
qu'en fait ils mettent en fait leurs
figures de proue seydoux bof moi je peux
je peux te dire que j'aime bien double
enfants vrai parce que je le connais
j'ai regardé les vidéos honnêtement ce
que tu as envie de faire après 30
secondes de visionnage et même montré à
ludwig lui-même sans comprendre après 30
secondes il ya une chose que tu as envie
de faire c'est de zapper il est
insupportable en fait tu peux rien il
passe pas du tout en vidéo donc tu peux
le push autant que tu veux je la veux
monter une fois en anglais j'avais m
mais bon un amant russe c'est pire
d'accord en russie là une manière de
parler de premier de la classe qui est
insupportable en fait c'est tu peux pas
en fait c'est pas il a pas de langage
internet quoi tu vois mais met donc en
fait tu peux envoyer mille euros sur par
stream 2000 à voir des studios de télé
de caméraman de machin de montage
puisque niveau cali c'est super c'est
vraiment level télévision donc tu peux
investir dans les 50 cent mille euros
par mois si tu veux ça peut pas
fonctionner il faut s ajoutent d'un mot
six cavaliers simple la barre la partie
d'ailleurs et les monstrueuses de l'eau
niveau là je sèche padam français qui
est ici à d'un procès qu'adam 6 d'avancé
4 dames francesca dossier remet à dieu
qui est brun 3 oui je sais mais bon ça
avec sont conséquents mais si cet
emprunt c'est 4 km non non je sais enfin
de façon c'est en soi mais l'effet
retour 8 et il va lui placé à mon avis
nommé run au coude avant il pouvait à
passe d'acheter un genre mais s'il
pouvait pas vu d'un mot 6
5 ça faisait deux nuls je pense qu'il y
avait des trucs alors attendu coups des
coups il ya un pion ouais mais c'est
hyper dangereux pour le roi d'ailleurs
donc l'ouverture
c'est la ligne joué par correspondance
maintenant ce g3 roi g2 qui au passage
introuvable si tu connais pas et les
noirs n2f ont retrouvé du con tre jeu et
c'est toujours un peu me pour les bleus
mais très solide mais là c'est hyper
choix de regarder des dames 1 d'un
machin dame prend f5 sa menace très mat
mesdames machin dame un tour f1 moi je
pense et damien traille fin d'année puis
on prend g6 et puis on prend et a pas de
défense
d'ailleurs je commence à me dire demain
puis on prend g6 d'un machin roger cats
et un matin mais il ya peut-être un truc
que les statuts ce raid pour les noirs
futur karl aussi parce que visuellement
j'aurais pas eu si peur que ça avec les
noirs mais en fait plus rien nous
pouvons dépasser le pion jaequi emprise
et quel est le rôle plus faible c'est ça
la vraie question de potes je commence à
adorer en fait la position blanche mais
on définirait plus je regarde moi je
trouve deux coups assez cette seconde
conduite
il vient de temps qu'à une minute à la
mairie d'alma quatre jeux dans le 17
c'était ça ça pointe t il faut y penser
après la minute de réflexion mais à
cassis grellier dam des cinq tours fc
est sans doute ça gagne gros gros niveau
de juin c'est un outil qui puisse 4,62
dans le web on n'a pas mis l'évaluation
je préfère d'ailleurs permettra pour le
3 minutes quand il ya moins de temps
c'est plus facile donc que 3 ou un peu
la mode un c5 est pas le plus joué que
deux quais du coup
john wayne il joue c'est sain comme la
vie pour éviter la ligne à base de
fouday de calamane là il ya deux coups
il ya ces cinq ou à trois donc là c'est
un pur isolé n'y a pas le foot cases
noires situe français qu'a donc c'est
assez particulier
j'aurais tendance à dire ça ça dépend
toile et leur nom à sa dépense que cités
rivales à mettre un cas valls est un
fonds b sert par exemple je pense était
assez content ouais mais d'un autre côté
si tu réussis à faire des cinq là c'est
sûr que tu es mieux avec les blancs
après c'est ça c'est il ya du bon et
moins alors dessin tout de suite je
pense que tout offert à meyreuil
t'empêche commandé 5 octobre
thaon retard qu'elle et 17 peut-être un
dessin qui est v6 même qui est des cas
il ne fera pas des 5es les peurs de haut
qui simplifie trop annoncé quand tu es
quelqu'un dessin qui a fait aussi je
pense ça et tu perds trop de temps à
regarder les fous non mais là il menace
vraiment des cinq mais tu as peut-être
carré lieu c'est ici voilà c'est ça donc
je sais pas si les gens sont courants
pour ce conte la motivation il ya 17
heures de vidéos de vlad sur pied isolés
qui sont fantastiques
certains noms sur ton site non way
quelqu'un ait pu mettre le lien tu la
regardes et une fois deux fois
enfin que je le regrette je crois que je
le regarde d'ailleurs magie mais en fait
je la regardais des eaux jusqu'au
j'étais le premier à l'avoir vu avec
après toi parce que j'ai corrigé
quelques trucs avant qu'il soit sorti
j'ai tous rentrés dans leurs 10 à la
main passe consignes et pour avoir les
parties pour les exos il y en a
certaines positions que j'ai beaucoup
aimé que j'ai fait c'est pas une dizaine
de fois en en cours ouais et qui ont
bien fonctionné
le boss des blues exode il a fait un
énorme boulot rhin ouais bah c'est
quelqu'un qui peut pas faire un truc mon
pas bien donc quand tu fais plus frileux
honnêtement je suis un peu pareil juste
je suis moins fort mais après c'est pas
qu'une question niveau échec pour faire
quelque chose de bien pas parce que tu
es moins fort tu fais quelque chose
forcément de mieux ou moins bien
oui oui non mais hier je suis
perfectionniste quand je fais un truc
jeu
bien enfin je veux le faire bien je
dirais pas toujours c'est vrai qu'on n'a
pas fait de chapitre là dessus par
exemple ce talent fou de cannes noires
que l'autre l'a plus que généralement
pas les tasses tidiane bâ attentats foot
rouge et 5h 6h 4h et le h5 pour forcer
faut prendre cette épreuve 7 mai mais en
fait c'est les fous de casement qui
s'échangent entre août à des cas de
figure où tu as des cavaliers prendre 3
f30 a été il ya des lignes à la mode
avec les blanc ou couleur inverse où tu
laisses ton fou tu joues le pur isolé
avec les blancs jardin tulle les noirs
ont cure isolé je passe tu vois moi tue
des cirques à vif cavaliers bk tout cas
nous sommes prêts ou des trois dans les
noirs en pions des 5 et je veux moi j'ai
toujours l'ambition c'est mieux pour les
blancs mais la dame h3 ça va commencer
faudra être solide mais du coup c'est
hyper intéressant un peu ce que est ce
que des cinq est pas un coup tu te
rendes le pion prouverait la pollution
est efficace surtout que j'adore jouer
ouais moi dans les plus isolées
maintenant j'aime bien les sacrifiés de
temps en temps et après l'attaqué mais
ce que j'aime bien c'est de le faire
quand j'ai encore une tour qui peuvent
coulisser ad'ailleurs d'ailleurs dans le
dvd
j'ai trouvé alors il ya on a demandé si
j'ai corrigé le dvd non j'étais juste
dit de trois conseils pour la mise en
tête quand j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait une
erreur au niveau de l'ordre des trucs
j'ai trouvé une erreur dans une analyse
de vlad c'est rare quelle vidéo et ce
qui est hyper le masque c'est la plus
belle partie du dvd et une erreur c'est
la cale l'ordinateur se rend pas compte
des buts c'est la partie ce witten
jusqu'au 20 je sais pas si tu te
rappelles donc il dit que c'est une
masterpiece il expliquant que s'il ne
monte
il explique hyper bien voilà bravo quand
je fais le court je l'expliqué aussi
mais ça marche un peu moins même genre
il l'a monde vita nous montrent ils pas
de relief ils le montrent à agri chucky
baguel fendent pensait cette fantastique
et après dans la partie je sais pas si
tu te rappelles à la fin il dit que les
noirs rate une nulle ouais ce qui est
vrai sauf qu'en fait si tu remontes du
coup au coude avant les blancs rate un
gain hallucinant en fait quand tu
comprends qu'un nul sur ce qu'il a joué
il a joué le coup normal et l'autre a
pas vu et a perdu
tu anticipes tu as un bien que j'ai fait
chercher à des grands maîtres
ils ont beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
trouver alors alors que ray alors qu'ils
savent qui est un gain mais parce que je
leur dis ce que tu leur diras
désapprouve l annuler
il y est ils ont ils galèrent énormément
mais v'là de la montre dans le truc mais
il pense que c'était nul parce que
l'ordi mais nul mais en fait j'ai
cherché un moment est en fait ya
vraiment un gain mais c'est fou mais je
te l'envers si tu veux qu'est ce que
c'est
d'ailleurs c'est beau et en exaucé un
exotique forme un partir de quel niveau
le dvd puis isolé bon on va pas se
mentir c'est un
alors après j'étais et honnêtes a des
gars qui ont écrit quatre essence à l
avaient fait progresser
mais à six mois j'avais plutôt à partir
de 710 700 mhz et a déjà en 1300 qui
m'ont écrit qu'ils ont il m'a fait
progresser ça m'a permis de comprendre
des choses dans le jeu en général mais
c'est vrai que c'est ça c'est la proche
trêve l'a d'ailleurs très classique
genre qui montre l'évolution de la
théorie de se divertir de ses positions
pardon genre ça commence par les grands
classiques les premières parties de ce
passif quand faire des cinq par
l'atypique en d5 et un quelqu'un quelque
1 100 des 5s qu'il y aurait de poncer
après avoir après avoir vu le dvd il
regarde que des cinq à tous les coups
non non il l'a rendu il a vendu
franchement accessible après voilà si
vous avez 2000 c'est juste parfait si
vous avez 2003 c'est même encore mieux
si vous avec un sens franchement vous
allez apprendre des trucs mais il faut
ça dépend un quinqua sans qu'ils aient
genre en mode vraiment casu couasnon
1,15 sent qu'il ya vraiment envie de
passer quarante heures sur 1
sur un format ouais c'est ça ouais ouais
en fait on quand t'es qu'un sens tu
passes 40 50 heures dessus c'est est
prêt à faire ce boulot là tu va
progresser mais faut vraiment que soit
1,15 sans qu'ils soient dans l'esprit de
vouloir le faire quoi en jetant son idée
c'est fou j'ai cinq noms achi souverain
schiste je pense façon c'est clairement
fouge et ce alors n'y a pas d'âme prend
juste pour rire skaff il ya tout
s'achète
l'incubateur d'ailleurs c'est pas sûr
qu'ils aient pas fait défaut c'est
peut-être le meilleur ou en tout cas
qu'elle est première dame proche 7
matches c'est sûr
puis en prenant 10 est moche c'est fou
prend le coup tu regardes le plus
maintenir puis on prend food et 4 tu te
fais viscères mais moi je m'en fous je
sens que je ne suis pas sûr que ça
marche pas donc vous prend vous g5
s'agit si florent puis on prend ça me
prend on va le voir une façon valider
ces drames une histoire sur la troisième
celle là c'est la partie mais moi par
exemple j'ai appris des trucs dans les
bd met à prier quand même pas mal de
trucs que je connaissais et heureusement
pour moi vous dire mais j'ai appris des
trucs clairement au retour on ici le
coup qu'on regarde normalement l'idée
c'est de ramener la dame de la tour
pendant 6 kg cat et damashek mathieu 4
et 4 taureaux un salaire forme je vois
pas quand il défend et comme l'a très
vite pourtant je vois pas de défense
fait surtout il veut te retrouves
cavaliers caricature la tourache froid
au pire quelques points 4
en cadets tour j'ai trop 100 kg kate et
d'un marché de masse 8 non en fait il
était toujours trois quarts a lieu
quatre faut prendre 4 ou prend 1 400 g
iii fou g6 a implosé sista raison du
coût mais bon tour 3 4 tours age 3 dawn
m6 m6
damages 7 c'est fou prend 1,4 milliard
matin à ces sas on avait du coup
peut-être que toro 5 n'en doute
c'est ça son idée alors j'y crois pas du
tout après croire aux échecs n'existe
pas de ça marche ça marche pour nom
matin un problème c'est tours 3 1 qui
avait lieu quatre tours j'ai trois quand
même à la main ce thème à chaque match
c'est pas un dvd c'est une vidéo série
qu'est sur le site de kiev à régler ça
s'appelle le pion désolé je ne sais pas
s'il ya quelqu'un qui peut mettre à lire
dans le chatt tours 5
non car il est ok tu n'as pas tord g5 à
l'ajesaia pas fou prend 0,3 et 0,6 à
ouais sauf que je retour 3 sat avec
tours h3
on attend le coup d'avant je veux juste
mettre l'ordi au coude avant je gagnais
pas sur un jeu troyat fois je n'en ai
qu'un voyage 7 chez moi j'avais vu
plonger 3 la siam est un fou justice
maintenant voilà temps reste sur le
direct ou les narguer incroyable ces
deux dames et qu'elle nettoie ses infos
faut avoir les nerfs pour trouver cette
défense bagri tout rappelle ce qu'il
avait dit de duda à la suite de leur
match à moscou
il avait dit que ça va donner
l'impression de jouer comme fritz 3 un
ordinateur pas fort en fait des copies
qui avait dit sa grille duke avait dit
ça de la part de duda il a dit je veux
continuer les rites qui jouait sans s'en
répartir d'ouverture ouaip il a aussi
dit que je veux comme un havre un
ordinateur faible ce qui venant de la
part de guy cloutier pas un compliment
je te rassure
ouais mais moi ce que j'avais compris
c'est qu'ils est il de serre mais qu'ils
aient des tricks mais qui connaissait
reynolds verture salut c'est pas du tout
un compliment quoi ouais mais c'est
c'est le fameux débat qu'on peut avoir
milan est ce qu'on préfère quelqu'un qui
bosse beaucoup qui a bien préparé ou
quelqu'un qui veut n'importe quoi au
début et après qui peut retourner à
toutes les positions
elle a gagné ça là autant celle là elle
est impressionnant parce qu'on a besoin
qu'il espère complètement défoncé or
dans l'autre choc j'ai pas tout vu j'ai
vu un moment on a vu qu'il y avait une
question je n'ai loupé fonsorbes
non mais en fait dans la vision des pays
l'est joué comme ça c'est qu'ils aiment
pas non non mais ça je suis complètement
d'accord ils n'aiment pas se met
d'ailleurs
moi quand j'ai un corner pour jouer même
pas non
mais d'où d'assécher pas il ya un côté
que j'aime bien c'est parce qu'il a
l'air sympa quoi
oui parce que je m'entends mais aussi
avec les nantis avec lui mais c'est pas
du tout joueur qui te plaît
habituellement je te le dis tout de
suite on n'aime pas trop ça après vos
thèmes aussi ce que t'es pas forcément
j'aimerais bien calculé aussi vite que
lui enfin si tu calcules aussi vite que
lui je suis tout de suite tu serai plus
fort que lui ben spies asie au largement
sans aucun doute mais bon deux donnent
non de da pour la faune très
impressionnant ça c'est des italiens qui
a été très à la mode ya quelques années
d'ailleurs j'en ai joué j'avais gagné
une partie pour moi important touche pas
de france contre de mute à cette idée de
ramener le foot en g3 et les noirs avons
essayé de le pousser f5 où on bouge et
câblées l'idée c'est de protéger g5 et
jouer h5
bizarrement le pro protégés de plongée
cinq mois et sur des catés seconde bons
coups aussi mais j'ai 4 kvh 4 puis on
prend des cats en dogme le pion et c'est
un bordel et noël sinon le plan logique
c'est callière frankel 3 contre les
cases blanches est d'ailleurs l'autre
jour on a vu une partie de doda où il
avait dominé carmona sur sa tétine oui
on a vu une telle partie mais je me
disais mathieu la queue à 2 2 0 on n'en
parle pas mais en fait il ya déjà 2 0
pour duda way et j'aime ça va fait la
réflexion et il a l'air en super forme
en réalité avait commencé avant le match
que sow allait gagner le match
moi je n'étais que bg je mets des 55
vient aussi mort mais moi je pensais
qu'il allait finir à le gagner le match
de trois points à la fin après le début
de match de duda je me faisais la
réflexion de me dire mais si si dubaï
dans cette forme là en fait j'ai
quasiment envie de te dire des sceaux
n'a aucune chance parce qu'il est
monstrueux mais c'est une petite
surprise mais bon compte en nature prend
du plomb métaux de la tour et frais des
quatre mais il réfléchit c'est l'art qui
pensent à pied en bout j'aurais jamais
fait ça
never mais bon après que je capte au
récent et il va te dire pourquoi ta joie
g5
alors victoire depuis tout à l'heure ce
troll spam le spam le chat gros on a dit
que j'avais fait une vidéo sur les pions
connectés dont parlait mathieu après
c'est à toi de la chercher un verre au
bout d'un moment si des pions connectés
dont c'est le truc de fou de couleurs
opposées dont tu parlais tout à l'heure
j'ai déjà agi au moment où tu la fais ta
vie tu as fait une vidéo
il ya une vidéo qui est faite de sua les
sorties à un an au bout d'un moment on
va pas à passer une demi heure at
expliqué le truc quoi tu vas voir le
cours et même en gros faut mettre le roi
il faut à deux cases une belote et que
le fou attaque le champion ouais mais
bon faut qu'ils voient une vidéo de
suicide puisque la halle aveugle à mon
avis tu y arriveras pas bah ouais en
gros l'idée c'est que ça fait nul parce
que le fou peut sacrifier contre les
deux pions mais tu as deux façons de
défendre il y en a qu'une qui marchent
tard mais t'inquiète pas il va il va y
va la regarder du dic du rmi des liens
et tout juste séreuse pas à mes
questions mille fois au bout d'un moment
c'est pas la maternelle quoi bon du coup
non mais on fait sérieux aussi c'est pas
clair notre équipe à laquelle vers 4 me
et les blonds m'annonce au train près
pour choix des quatre et ouvrir la
position ils ont affaire de fous leroy
engin est un peu plus hier que le roi g7
c'est vraiment compliqué watch un tempo
non c'est toi que tu es joueur tu fais
une flèche au champ des fouilles lisa
simon s'est qualifié pour juger trois tu
chasses les pièces tout à petit mes
règles sont l'ajout de game of donc
comment est ce qu'on continue
elle fut roi charles logique hein il va
repartir qu'à rédiger un g3 je serai d41
gens mais faudra tigers 4 tours est
fluide les noms on peut donc amasser
5000 vos menaces etc et enfin je crois
probablement donc comment faudra voir ça
c'est une vraie question c'est de moi je
crois que les noix ont très bien je la
dernière série coup-là américaine arca
doublé parce que foucault f4 on n'a pas
trop envie il va prendre de g
et après il va transférer sur la colonne
j'ai les pièces jean roy à chaque fois
f7 puis le tour j'ai mis ce tour g6 et
taper son g2 mais même si j'ai pas comme
ça il ya peut-être après des cats vite
donc laquelle branche ne marche plus
parce qu'elle 3d fondu donc x 5
on va faire cavaler j'ai un nom et puis
j'ai 3
kg 3
ouais non il va pas claires justes en
allemand je n'ai aucune idée de qui est
mieux c'est peut-être d'égal quand on
s'est pendu également le truc que j'ai
du mal à comprendre c'est pourquoi sort
est dense
j'attends qu'il joue pas le style de
match dans le il n'y arrive pas pour
l'instant je ne connais ni les mieux
rires non mais même là c'est quand même
son choix très catchy g5y cette variante
un peu un peu bordélique
j'ai l'impression que ces douze acquis
réussi à l'amener sur son terrain il ya
un mec qui dit quelque chose dans le
chat c'est gentil pour moi mais je suis
pas d'accord avec lui dans la
compréhension des échecs les deuxièmes
français je trouve les plus
impressionnants ces camps et et de gras
aujourd'hui on est des paies des deux
pires c'est peut être pour ça qu'il vous
préfère non un niveau comprend sont pas
un peu maso dans certains types de
pollution et au dessus mais tactiquement
j'ai toujours été meilleur noël les gens
pour soi est un juge de calcul bien mais
je suis très lent surtout maintenant
mais non c'est ce qu'on dit c'est alors
j'ai 3 qui avait les h5 et maintenant tu
as un flash de donc et tu peux faire
j'ai quatre parents ça serait terrible
qui leur donnerait la cazelle kaduna tu
peux pas rater ça tourne ça commence à
tourner ce que le fauteuil comme bien
d'autres en fait on n'a jamais vraiment
su si souhaité fait pas la partie
parfaite en réalité un puisque tu as
comme tu as dis bonne prépa et
finalement ouais ça fait mal c'est
quatre ans puis silva fait bien le pion
de carl toujours pas compris arrivé j'ai
pu encaisser 5
ouais c'est ça ouais parce que j'ai
pensé en plus ton premier fils ici pour
avoir conduit cavaliers pour taper
encore une fois aux quatre salaires
compliqué pour et c'est ce que je ferai
tout pour un prix équivalent f6 non tu
gagnes le pion en force au regard du kg
1 le fou c'est ce qui va jouer va être
le cavalier en effet 6
il ya combien de gm france en activité
je m'appelle quand je suis passé j'étais
le 33e c'est la gironde c'est facile de
se rappeler mais maintenant il donne
alors 56 ben tu arrives à prendre ces
quatre cas valises des deux dames prend
à deux non je pense tu va le prendre ce
pur a de ce fait précis nous gens mais
je crois que les points 4 mais je pense
que tu seras les le mouvement jade ou
pas moi je leur ai pris un web attaque
b2 en danger c'était sèche alors ça ça
va être complètement gagnant mais
attends rien à [ __ ] couleurs reposer
quand même mais même si ça doit y est
gagnant géographie toujours faire gaffe
en juste un conseil faites paquet
cheesecake pour échanger les cavaliers
des faut toujours se méfier des défauts
de couleurs opposées
donc il faut essayer de garder les
cavaliers elle doit être gagnante mettez
ces genres de finale où tu peux te rater
une 10 contre une cinquante c'est chaud
est ce qu'on connaît la programmation
des autres matches car moi j'ai pas
trouvé retrouver ses petits j'ai juste
vu qu'il y avait un vote le 3 ils ont
défini la date des demi finales et
finales se jouent non il n'y a pas
vraiment de date et puis le match qui
est le 3 connaissant les les
organisateurs je préfère pas l'annoncer
trop vite parce que les changements de
dates sont quand même assez fréquent et
en et c'est pour ça que c'est pas encore
ils les autres matches aller en fait
j'imagine qu'ils aient un tournoi qui
commence sur une autre plateforme
bientôt ils veulent juste faire avant et
après ça non ouais je pense françois tu
peux dire sur chaque 24 lots tellement
oui mais magnus tout est d'ailleurs
assez mongie révélé qu'une personne
infokiosque sommes allés à voir les
caméras bientôt pour les bretons - a
pour le championnat du monde oui mais il
n'ya pas les candidats pour les
candidats j'en ai entendu parler mais
j'ai pas vu des annonces officielles
il manquait juste on a même annonce ya
pas de dessin qui on prend fourbe et 5
qui gagne tout de suite ait fait pas
attendre je fous oui il faut prend et
qui avait plongé trois arrêts mais ce
genre de truc en fait que tu vois pas
quand le match est dur gérard quand les
partis sont faciles sur un truc que tu
vois et quand tu es déjà dans le dur ce
que la partie a eu beaucoup de tactique
tu rates genre de trucs
ou après il veut peut-être jeu des 5e
jeu tranquille il ya rien bon jeu les
candidats à distance non non non
naturelle chez soi même en mai mais
devait eu sur les deux prochains
candidats mais est-ce que les deux
prochains candidats rentrent en compte
le candidat de d'avril ça me semble
vraiment que c'était écrit suis qui se
termine en tout cas ce qui est cool
c'est que râler caméra pour le match
championnat du monde et ça ça va
vraiment être sympa non parce que
honnêtement ait manqué que ça tu vas te
régaler ah bah oui déjà a déjà on avait
beaucoup de monde qui a regardé avec
nous même sans les caméras on était déjà
là la chaîne la plus suivie pour les
candidats là ça va être génial
non mais c'est juste après limites
ouais si si c'est quand même important
ça une des meilleures images de
championnat du monde
moi j'ai mangé connu que les derniers
que carlson quasiment c'est la fameuse
quand il fait une énorme gaffe contre
allende il ya une vidéo c'est les gars
essayer de la retrouver si quelqu'un
peut la mettre
elle est géniale il joue son coup il se
rend compte qu'ils viennent de gaffer il
prend son stylo il n'arrive pas à écrire
elle pose et la vidéo elle est
fantastique et linehan que je trop vite
rate le truc gagnant et la magnus
soulager tombe sur l'app store la table
genre ok maintenant jouer un peu cette
partie de la gagne 1 c'est la partie qui
change d'un salaire complètement gagnant
il a bien joué d'ailleurs maintenant il
va reprendre g3 ça va gagner il va
revenir mais c'était une partie
importante 1 où il a rejoué dans le
style de vallouise non tacite à miss à
partir du moment où il a réussi un jeu
de la finale et aviné facile mais avant
il a quand même compliqué un peu les
choses mais cette fois on a juste mieux
jouer génération et sausset typique du
joueur ça je me sens que ça dépend
beaucoup de lui un quand il joue bien en
fait 500 qui peut battre tout le monde
elle est facile mais il va être assez
dur d'être constant à ce niveau là même
âge à lui des interviews avec les échecs
ça le soul est un peu un saut les
préparations la théorie etc
ac c'est marrant parce que c'est un
joueur hyper théorique m'a mis à bosser
tellement pour tout ça alors ça tu
connais par coeur tout j'avais bossé ça
il ya 15 ans âge légal et les nouvelles
variantes
ouais j'ai vu des parties ouais mais il
y avait eu un tournoi au cap d'agde avec
guelph on y vend tout qu'un hand à la
vieille époque
à l'époque les gens et il avait un jeu
presque que c'est une bonne chose qu'un
jeu tongiens raf way et ça avait été la
mode il ya eu deux trois parties
d'affilée du coup on avait tous regardé
mais on comprenait pas trop l'idée on
vous avez juste pour gerges des quatre
routes
c'est à cette date là j'ai un peu
regardé du coup ce truc là alors dit
c'est bizarre parce que c'est a
l'impression que ça va vraiment pour les
noirs mais il fait que le pion sur
angers 5
ça te ralenti ta structure avec les
blancs si tu réussis est organisée à
pousser se retrouve assez bien c'est un
peu dans le truc il faut être hyper
précis actuellement c'est ça qui me
disent ouais ça c'est vrai t'as
l'impression à visu que ça va pour les
noirs il n'y a pas de problème mais
concrètement tatata tour qui se
retrouvent pas très bien placé est allé
pousser 5 qui traînent talent fou des
cinq qui est un peu bizarre tation g5
qui t'empêche de jouer comme d'habitude
[Musique]
ouais il loge au bail que je fous h3c
d'un chic
oui a pas que c'est dur aussi de trouver
une idée même les juges le foie h3g
abattage à l'échouage même pas me la
menace mais ok ça c'est logique qu'ils
veulent changer le père de tours et il
empêche pas franchement j'aurais fait
pareil tu peux être fier du match fait
des fous g2 ils échangent même faire
[ __ ] ans et si je veux la casse ces
cinq je sais pas mais c'est rien mais
c'est un peu pénible tard il faut
ajouter 5 direct la même pris 0 à ses
sept est ce qu'on est vraiment bien je
suis même pas sûr mais ça et c'est un
peu déplaisant c'est pas un truc cool et
blanc l'avantagé c'est un truc que tu
joues c'est plus dans le style de sosa
du coup oui mais quand il réfléchit
maintenant dans les grandes ligues
théorique n'a pas davantage donc
pourquoi pas faire ça c'est pas plus
bêtes qu'autre chose un espion
cette fois 5 pour empêcher quel point
six gains elle a pris à sable fait ça va
faire quoi tu peux mettre le fond des
trois ans faut faire gaffe
est-ce que je peux jouer à 6 puis on
prend encore content je sais tu auras de
probablement g46 la foule regardez g6
aussi j ai pas pensé
le truc c'est que si tu fais j'ai si
celle-ci se faire ce cadeau refaire maso
un jour fuite
ça les pions qui peuvent être faits non
mais tu vas majorettes rue qui voit tout
de suite mais j'ai 6e j'aime pas ça
double tranchant tu peux me mettre nue
mais en fait 5 es tu peux être moins
murray tu peux juste touche à rien aussi
ouais c'est équilibré
le truc mais ça me faisait penser
peut-être alors quand tu sais pas quelle
est votre position
tu mets pas clair quel point c'est que
quand il joue faut bien tendre ams est
plus ambitieux et 6 ans et sur un truc
c'est que si un jour les tours
disparaissent et qui affolait fuite
c'est fini quoi c'est ça mais tu peux
aussi te retrouver avec des problèmes
avec les pions faible à la fin tu te
faire récolter les plans la fin tu peux
te rendra aussi à ça va être intéressant
maintenant franchement je suis pas
mécontent du début de match ce qu'on
s'en fout pas mal et pars ali est
d'ailleurs t'as pas l'impression que les
deux ont haussé leur niveau de jeu par
rapport la démarque parce que difficile
à dire pour l'instant le sens où il a
tellement dominé quand même mais à douta
clairement après 12' mine de rien il a
battu car on est numéro deux mondial
assez facile en parlant 3,02 le wef
justement à touches mais disons qu'ils
gagnent un peu contre le cours du match
on va dire jusqu'au bull est alors que
là il joue vraiment bien et d'ailleurs
loi et bullet car on n'a qu'a fait un
peu illusion on déduit mais trop d'écart
ça va trop vite des 5 intéressant parce
que tu arrives pas fait à 5 mois
j'aurais pas foutu mes pions sur blanc
de ce côté là mais
ouais moi non plus vrai que c'est que
pour les blancs il faut réussir à
échanger les tours et à sécuriser sa 5e
vraiment un jour tu étais dans la dèche
pour défendre je te mets trinquet rien
eu six en fait non parce que tu dois pas
faire foule bush qui avait lieu le 6
défend g7 et après tu peux faire un peu
ce que tu veux alors attention quand
même à ne pas se prendre un truc après
genre de tour ces trois fouilles 3 à 4
quelqu'un me dit non il est vietnamien
et philippins mais là ils jouent ils
jouent pour les états unis
oui j'ai menti craque
oui les philippins est d'ailleurs je me
rappelle il ya des jeux au top 12 il ya
un top stage à l'époque en division
française avec le club de clichy et il
est arrivé personne ne connaissait
vraiment on avait juste entendu que le
mec avait l'air fou bon en fait il était
quand même très très très très
impressionnant et tout s'est mal la même
guy compte qu'on adore critiquer quand
il est arrivé il y avait 15 ans a joué à
2007 2 perfs sa joie pas si mal mais bon
le problème de vie rythmée par seconde
le problème de geri c'est plus son
système nerveux comme dirait vlad plus
que son niveau de jeu en réalité
moi je pense que son il emprunte de
niveau de jeu peut être de trop vouloir
contrôler tenir ses nerfs mais pas que
cedar hill et quand magnus lui une
épaule du joug des trucs grand n'importe
quoi il peut perdre 15 coups c'est le
seul du top niveau qui peut pas en
kiosque ou même et radio 6 et 1 du fait
qu'il relie la réalise 3 alors dit mais
d'ailleurs magnus savez partie détruite
qui m'avait beaucoup impressionné c'est
un des rares qui fait pas que de l'ordi
c'est un prophète entre le système
nerveux que qu'il appelle qui est
mauvais dans le système nerveux où il a
un peu de mal à tenir ses nerfs et le
fait qu'il fasse que l'ordi chez lui en
fait les deux combinés il dit ça rend
fou
mais s'il ya un peu de ça quand ça
dessus ouais mais ça je pense ça se
corrige pas vous sa part il s'agit plus
rien y faire malheureusement
qui est mûr gens me dire que personne
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ça va
jouer deux 30 contre une transe l'argent
ce n'est plus le problème quand 80 est
comme ça c'est que doit pas prendre trop
de plaisir quand tu joues mais non mais
enfin j'ai un peu le même problème c'est
moi je jouis libye parlant on aime bien
intégrée tout le monde a peur de perdre
on est hyper quand ça devient compliqué
on ne sait pas trop d'un point fort donc
enfin ça l'était avant mais maintenant
on est un peu lent je commence à bien
aimer les blancs et de fou qui table sur
le pion insiste des 5
mais là il va se faire fixer à faire à
bab met une tour le plan b 4 et 6 tours
à trois tours à cette 6ème beaucoup
après le mec va mettre un gain d ouais
mais je pourrais aller chasser avec ces
trois noms s'alarmer pour les blancs
maintenant à bab bk salaires forêt
d'après-vous un top 3 des futurs
successeurs de carlson alors il sera
toujours là d'ici dix ans s'ils arrêtent
pas de jeu en fait ils menacent projet
de vous quand même faire attention
est ce que tu fais le cas tout foucades
faire mais ce que j'aime pas et caf 4
c'est que ça permet à tours latérales en
devenir bouffe et hi5 f4 j'aime pas du
tout donc je vais préférer faire des
caps tour à troyes b qu'elle s'était
bien j'ai donc si carlson haendel dans
milk en scène c'est pareil ou paraître
façon comparer ma page enfin disons
qu'on est dans une période creuse
enfin entre guillemets août à un énorme
joueur et a pas de numéro deux donc
c'est comme c'était nadal federer ou
quoi sans djokovic et nadal et federer
pour miner mais d'ailleurs non c'est
plus un jeu au cours d un wes et puis
c'est un djoko en fait en vrai qu'il
m'aimait tam et a pas de le truc c'est
comme si tu avais djoko et puis tu avais
nadal et federer blessé depuis cinq ans
quoi le truc c'est qu'à moi main il est
numéro deux comme assez clair
il ya ding m'a d'ailleurs dit ne vous en
avez pas parlé du tout ya dans les dents
les gentils méchants et il est peut-être
trop gentil il lui dont j'aime bien
j'aime j'aime beaucoup ce cas est ce qu
a dit vlad sur la phrase de votre venue
qu'est ce que tu veux devenir champion
du monde
est ce que tu veux vraiment devenir
champion du monde je trouve que c'est ce
qu'en fait car le cnca qui pour l
attaque est vraiment très frontalement
et lui faire très très mal
psychologiquement mais bon ce serait
très méchant quoi qui est au taquet bien
défendus comme ça tu vas c'est
intéressant comme débat est ce que tu es
prêt vraiment de à faire ça je pense pas
dans les joueurs actuels je pense pas
qu'ils aient des joueurs qui soient
vraiment mal intentionnés en dehors dans
le top 10 non pas revoir au revoir aux
que carlson sic m
il a dit quand il avait 18 ans quand il
a travaillé avec kasparov sais pas si
les gens sont au courant mais c'est
comme ça est dans une profession il a
toujours dit d'ailleurs et il a dit que
que kasparov était très bien préparés
qu'ils avaient beaucoup d'énergie
tactiquement très fort mais qui
comprenait mieux mieux léché que lui il
a pas dit de pour être prétentieux il a
dit parce qu'ils le pensent mais le pire
c'est que ce que tu as envie de te
contredire je suis pas sûr non mais sans
les trucs incroyables moi j'avais vu un
tas 24 quand il a quand ils achètent
plus qu'à l'âge mais jeunes infuser 15
16 17 18 ans est ce qu'on peut vous
compare à un mozart à mozart et répond
je crois que cette comparaison est juste
énorme et doit répondre un truc comme ça
j'ai envie de dire est ce qu'on vous
convoyage jésus-christ va dire oui je
pense que nous sommes à peu près égaux
enfin il a un ego surdimensionné mais
c'est tant mieux pour lui enfin c'est
bien mais c'est nécessaire en fait pour
le sony va bien sûr c'est nécessaire
pour le haut niveau
bien sûr bien sûr c'est pas une critique
en fait enfin à jouer c'est c'est normal
en fait pour un si grand champion
d'avoir cette mentalité là mais je suis
pas sûr que les autres joueurs du top
niveau en ce moment et cette même
mentalité
ouais un peu trop gentil ou un peu trop
passé qui leur maximum et roland titre
est clairement quand il fait copain
copain avec à rognan et à prix hyper le
rognon pendant que je pense qu'il peut
être méchant ouais très drôle
mojito mais je pense aux halles il peut
il avait ce qu'il fait et mais il lui a
manqué un truc un moment en fait des
gens je sais pas s'ils savent ce qu'il
était numéro 2 pendant très très
longtemps alors non il n'a jamais réussi
en fait à passer devant la marche était
trop haute et après il a craqué au
candidat chirac fut le cas l'année et un
toit des candidats où il est leader
aronian est hyper deux parties
consécutives et c'est pas su ou carson
gagne à londres je crois que celui
d'avant mais c'est peut-être seulement
carlson gagner mais il ya des phrases
mais il ya une fois il y avait un truc
qui m'avait beaucoup marqué c'est quand
j'étais vraiment jeune j'avais faim il
ya vingt ans à lausanne un open et il y
avait un oeil au masters avec des
milliards du monde les jeunes et à
l'époque avait nakamura qui étaient là
où il avait 18 ans peut-être lui qui
avait pour avoir la mentalité d'un
fonctionnement de la caméra mon avis je
pense
ils jouent contre à vau-l'eau kittin
alors les gens connaissent pas forcément
c'est un grand match
craignant qu'un peu disparu du truc
était très fort très jeune pas loin de
2700 meka jamais explosé 1 et n'a qu'à
moi fait que 4,5 d'un match 5
et il ya une autre partie fait une
ouverture un peu trop allait finalement
match et chaumet vos locaux pour le
meeting gagne un conte interviews
d'après parti qu'elle était la reine
nakamura son deuxième coup il n'a pas
voulu analyser plus la partie dit c'est
fini
à partir de là j'ai déjà gagné deux et
j'étais avec un ami français d'une liste
je poste a connu ouais je suis dit
[ __ ] il est prétentieux dit bah non
c'est normal il a raison arrête ça moi
ça m'avait complètement choqué ce que
moi j'aurais dit non mais c'était pas
clair bon ce n'était pas terrible
message ou tel je cherche toujours des
circonstances atténuantes
je trouve toujours du jeu pour
l'adversaire mais il a dit non mais le
mec il a fait une ouverture de maître
doit le défenseur est un
ça m'avait hyper impressionnant que
j'avais pas tellement pas cette
mentalité mais maso parlant qu'il a sa
base aux deux libye celle inverse la
libye veut des moyens pour sa part
s'ajoutent des bases on va dire langue
c'est de la merde je défonce
non mais c'est une mentalité revoir
après après c'est comme ça un hack avait
perdu 1 mais les meilleures analyses
franchement un jour faudrait faire une
vidéo si tu fait analyser une position
sérieusement libye est maso ensemble
c'est génial moi je comptais les points
c'est sur un échiquier terre entre path
analyse des fall est parti après traquer
les lieux ils sont jamais d'accord c'est
tellement opposées au niveau des styles
c'est fantastique
moi je suis entre les doutes à une fois
je suis pour au moins deux fois jeu pour
battre il va peut-être la gagne veillez
en trainde avec la terre de foot des cas
le pion un je pensais food est un outil
pareil je pense que juste france a
envoyé à en fait
adams et captivante où damas six
d'ailleurs j'ai pas le charisme
j'ai pas vu mon fils par une foule vite
je pense mais est ce que tu peux wafou
c3 hyper dangereux ouais mais jeudi la
paire de fou positions ouvertes et pion
à faible c'est il ya trop de petits
avantages là donc ça c'est un truc
typîque
quand vous avez perdu le fou contre fou
cavaliers essayer de jouer sur la
couleur du fou absent chez votre
adversaire
ici on a donc foot caché dans le fond de
classement les normands [ __ ] cases
blanches et un cavalier dont il faut
essayer de jeu sur 15 mois alors ça peut
paraître évident dit comme ça mais
souvent en oubliant ouais tiens prêt bon
ça peut aussi faire gaffe très
dérangeant là si tu laisses des cas tu
pourra plus le faire c'est pas con de
prendre le pion à la dameuse ah non il
adore livrés mais bon ça merde que je
fous kayem seafood presse que j'allais
dire
or la question ses titulaires sont pas
moins quatre noms seraient h4 je me
donne à 15 h 2 et après je te fais donc
moins quatre d'automne après il faut
prendre un cap je leur ai pas vus comme
des cartes sa gagne pas je pense qu'elle
gagne le pion à il va monter trop et tu
vas pouvoir affaiblir les pions ces
machins je pense dam des quatre prix
three ça gagne tu as far as catch à
faire pouët 5 tu vas faire à 56,8 le
parfum hugo boss en bonne voie mais le
truc c'est que rare deux pions passé
puis en avoir un ici un ici sur deux
pions passé contre 1 tu gagnes a pas la
règle de la diagonale 28 de diagonale
différentes moi je suis dit ça gagne sa
nv holding sa graine on le prend oui
mais oui mais parce c'est une logique
après le truc c'est que si tu joues pas
dans des 4 da peut-être bob cone en un
mais c'est sûr ça gagne deux pions passé
mathieu contre un c'est fantastique en
finale toutes couleurs opposées quant à
pied en plus et après un fou pour être
des deux blocs le pion passes adverses
et soutient les deux pieds en page web
bah il va soutenir celui qui en a cinq
suivants à sète il sera trop c'est sûr
en a cinq qui sera soutenu tu vas
pouvoir mettre le f4 qu'on tourne avec
le roi je sais pas quand tu dois gagner
ça la gamme n'ont subi que tu ailles
voulu empêcher ces cinq ma tête il veut
pousser 5 provoquer des trois pour
pâques est fou des trois fous ici au
coeur fou à vii
on y fait un gâteau ou c'est pas d'une
logique implacable
j'ai pas aimé le fait qu'ils retardent
la montée de son roi l'adoption du roi
fou b4 j'aurais préféré voir un roi
commencé à monter quoi voir comment ça
na 3 5 il est plus dans le quart et
n'ont donc pas de saint perdon asus
annonce à leur famille aux séismes est
bon je laisserai pas le pu aller jusque
là
fu détroit doit être jouée mais la
nature argentat plus poussées 5/4 e 5 e
fois de suite il veut gagner partout en
fait 3 2 les verts après eux
bref the après tu fais pousser 5,5 fois
chi x files mais il faudra qu'il fasse
gaffe à la webcam détroit machin tu
prends pas juste h5
non mais ça va complètement gagné ça
c'est pas possible je peux pas y croire
en fait crise rouages s est jamais tu
vas commencer à faire pousser de 3 et h4
il prend jamais le pion pouces et 5 des
trois fossés cinq fautes 3 c'est très
fort très 3,6 h41 ça ça gagne maintenant
tu fais roi g3 g4 d'un joli à mai ces
finales footballeur reposer c'est mon
pain par majorque j'en ai gagné dès le
ce1 et du fou d'ailleurs je pense que je
prend une option sur un ballon rond en
c6 est sûr c'est que je vibre au
patronat non ça c'est sûr ces kenyans
hockey surtout pas prendre ce qu'il ya
des deux il ya paroisse de leur jeu 3 au
f4 maladresse que j'allais dire on passe
par derrière on arrive en paix si c'est
fini en fait les choix qu'il peut pas se
tromper nous sommes parfois prendre il
n'y a pas de menace roi mais roy g3 je
comprends pas ce qui peut arriver en
fait c'est franchement à ce qu'est ce
que tu fais contre ce plan là qui me
paraît inéluctable
je vois pas comment on arrête ça en fait
on y porte qui soit on est pour donc
pour un bon match pour moi je me lavais
comme ça c'est la même mais la fille l'a
fait comme ça manas reprend les manettes
parole c'est sûr qualité gagnante ça l'a
d'ailleurs ils ont à peu près le même
élan sur le site
ouais bien gagner la finale mais je
crois quoi se faire rentrer dedans enfin
je pouvais quand maxime c'était
visuellement gagnant est
ce qui change avec les blancs assez
régulièrement sonore d'un jeu lattaque
congrès de tours j'ai joué aux deux arts
est irresponsible reste plus très
longtemps avant le 5 + 1 je sais pas si
ce sera avantagé dans les autres cadence
mais en tout cas moi je trouve qu'il
joue très vite un saut mais juste lots
du coup en bullet match pourrait
peut-être en 3 il est peut-être plus
avantagés meadows en bullet m'a vraiment
mais j'ai l'impression que là le match
on vraiment en train de tourner en
faveur de duda parce qu'il a plus de
manquer ça près en 3 + 1 il ya sept huit
parties tu peux vite à un moment donné m
4-0 fin 4-0 c'est possible à n'importe
quel moment en fait ben ouais je
m'assois c'est que sol il a quand même
c'est la classe 1 il est fort donc il
peut revenir dans tous les cas mais faut
pas qu'il tient trop là les deux
prochaines faudrait pas bien toi qui
gagnent moins une
alors le vainqueur de ce match
rencontrera mathieu en demi finale le
vainqueur du match n'a qu'à murat
fedoseyev un talent nous avait posé la
question ce qu'on pensait c'est que
est-ce que feydeau peut le faire moi
j'aurais dit non il ya pas longtemps
mais avec ce qu'on a vu récemment
d'ailleurs il a battu dans un match
amical c'est possible après on n'a qu'à
favori un ferment
par contre duda si je joue comme ça il
peut clairement le faire 1 contre mc
assez dur là c'est l'épiné dans le pied
de temps oui mais le truc c'est que si
le moi j'ai l'impression que tu n'as
qu'à je sais pas si je me trompe ou pas
mais j'ai l'impression que n'a qu'à le
jour où tu as quelqu'un qui lui empêche
de placer ses tricks il tilt
complètement mais il ya une crise parce
plan b n'a qu'à n'a qu'à cinq gars comme
d'hab on passe selon lui par le soleil
se fait défoncer parce qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à tenir dans les tricks mais un
continent mais si tu as quelqu'un qu'il
qui le tient dans les tricks en fait il
n'a pas de plan b anaqua un haka on
fasse à carson en pl us by les derniers
speech est donc c'était quoi ya deux
trois ans quand ils sont joués en finale
je dis pas de bêtises c'était hyper
chaud bas il y en a un qui était hyper
chaud lot il a gagné assez facilement qu
il me semble là ça s'est joué à peu non
car on dit il ya perdu je vois personne
peut battre la caf 1 pour moi car le
seul bon il se dira pas en finale
évidemment il sera éliminé avant mai
mais karl seine s'ils jouent contre nac
a pour moi il a battu déjà deux fois sur
des gros scores en speech s il est
forcément favori car le san ouest et ça
on nous dit 2016 2017 mais 2017 était
facile 2016 est hyper chaud c'est ce qui
me semblait way concernant 6 à 3,4 en
mai wef et dossier donc l'autre jour là
bas tu es dans un match d'entraînement
donc ceux là en plus c'est un match en 3
+ 0 donc c'est une cadence qui acquit
avantages déjà mon aka et tout mais bon
après il était en train de stries ménaka
et cetera tu as et pas toujours il
n'était pas en condition idéale mais
psychologiquement forcément c'est mieux
de ce que j'ai aussi vu se prendre
d'isère fait d'os face à ana kg afp neuf
se prendre une adoption justin mais t'as
pas l'impression qu'il a beaucoup fait
qu'il a fait que ça pendant confinement
et qu'il a progressé oui oui j'ai
apprécié ce oui en plus juste après il
avait joué contre maxime ou maxime petit
stream et donc c'est il a moins
l'habitude donc c'est pas facile mais
après d'accueil avait pas l'air si on
tinto que ça donne
il ya quand même plutôt bien je comme
max banon mais du coup ça va être un
match intéressant moi j'avais
personnellement les battre au début
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours peur de ça mais
ça peut enfin moi j'étais rassuré par
parleurs head's up parce que je me dise
in aka avait une un avantage
psychologique sur fait de cf le fait que
le dernier gros truc qu'ils aient joué
ensemble fait das le baht je pense que
sarba complètement les cartes un jeu
je pensais que tu maintiennent un gros
avantage psychologique quand tu as perdu
le dernier match en fait l'intérieur
après je pense qu'ils sur quatre heures
de match sans stream il se sent toujours
favori c'est des mecs ont des esgaulx
monstreux je pense pas qu'il s'est remis
en question après une défaite sur
internet et pas trop le chemin l'as roma
tentation non non non ça c'est sûr mais
c'est plus pour fedoseyev que pour nacac
c'est important je pense que pour n'a
qu'à ça change au final réellement pas
grand chose mais pour fait das je pense
que ça a changé énormément aux multiples
naka 3005 ses fourneaux en bullet ambühl
attendu les autres mines 2,33 non mais
il est impressionnant on a cassé senaka
sur internet il est impressionnant alors
qu'arsène faut pas oublier qu'il était
numéro 1 sur le site avant mais comme il
a monté son chemin et montella il a
racheté un autre site
il joue plus trop sur site ce qu'elle
est étrangère ce qui est de bonne guerre
ce qui peut se comprendre les mots ce
qui peut se comprendre après ça va ça
peut lui coûter aussi carl scène de plus
jouer sur le site sur lequel tout le
monde vous ouais mais il jouait le coup
solide celle de beaucoup plus ce sera
une époque louis mais t'as pas les
meilleurs sur l'île chess lui dire pas
je veux dire par là que le fait de ne
plus s'entraîner sur czech comme c'est
quand même la plateforme honte à tout le
monde qu'ils jouent c'est quand même tu
vois sur ce format là ça peut être un un
petit handicap après et par rapport aux
mentalités j'ai une anecdote marrante
c'est laurence fraisse qui m'avait
raconté secafi rouge ya là il avait fait
un camp d'entraînement il ya quelques
années
sim avait annoncé qu'il y avait un
iranien hyper fort franchement on n'en
avait jamais entendu parler maintenant
on le connaît bien et ils avaient fait
d'église d'entraînement il avait 14 ans
et il en prenait à carson et genre il
montré aucun respect et car c'est la
sortie et la [ __ ] ils font chier les
petits avoir aucun respect mais venant
de carcassonne c'est tellement drôle
brive s'est pas dans le sens où des
c'est juste que quand ils arrivent et
quand il perd contre kasparov la partie
cogné avec l âge conca sport il fini en
pleurs se produit c'est pas normal de
perdre même si ces castrations face à 13
ans je pense c'est ça 13 ans et il quoi
il fait une nulle hyper l'autre ouais et
donc ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
fait sa demande qualité là qui est
nécessaire pour le top top niveau et
mais comme a dit vlada vente
avant-hier il faudra voir si à un moment
il est capable de bosser de se faire
assez mal pour le top niveau après pour
art lui il n'y a pas longtemps à mes
soixante meilleur parti de fisher en
parallèle avec la biographie de talent
en fait quand il avait 17 ans fischer en
gros talith écrit c'est un joueur en
devenir très talentueux blablabla mais
il a un répertoire beaucoup trop naos
beaucoup trop p3 alors que tu sais qu'il
est il a eu un répertoire après qui
était juste le répertoire le plus large
du haut niveau et il disait dans les
finales technique qui jouait beaucoup
trop vite en pensant qu'elle était tout
nul théorique et du coup c'était
possible de le planter pour ses touts
les finales au tour étaient nuls sans
réfléchir en fait et
il a énormément bossé sans fisher après
en finale c'est devenu un monstre en
ouverture n'y avait pas plus monstrueux
cuit donc en fait c'est ses points
faibles du fisher de 17 ans sont devenus
quasiment ses points forts du fisher
accompli dix ans plus tard quoi et c'est
que du travail propos presque c'est que
ça c'est bien joué je prendrais 6 il va
avoir le point d'être en ligne de mire à
la fin de la variante là je t'annonce
que ça a été oublié mais il a eu lieu
que pour les tricks duda mais qu'est-ce
qui les voit vite parce que ça marche
vraiment il faudra un maxime il faut
prendre trois fous prend on peut pas
prendre ces 5,1 en relief ranger droit
est ce que la dame a le choix je crois
défunt avait sept ou la maxime qui
s'amarrent j'allais le dire mais tu
après c'est la question d'un guide à
contre à 1 12 da contre nac à 6 et duda
qui mène les dents sur des petits trucs
comme ça contre nakache que je t'assure
que naka il le détruit psychologiquement
bah ouais c'est ouais c est ce qu un
hacker peut se faire étriller par
d'audard oui mais pas tout le temps et
pente hindous da maxime [ __ ] ça va
fuser les les calculs ah mais oui mais
disons que naka je pense qu'il n'a
aucune possibilité de s'adapter en fait
je pense les tripes pour lui c'est
vraiment do dame me ressemble beaucoup
mais je suis assez d'accord
physiquement et physique
mais d'ailleurs dauda quand j'avais je
les inclus en équipe ce qui me laisse
aubry c'est qu'en fait il a une très
bonne technique en finale tout comme
maxime c'est normal en fait ils
calculent vicky ça m'avait vraiment
surpris en fait les joueurs qui calcule
vide et qui sont vraiment actifs sont
souvent bon final shirov par exemple si
tout le temps mais kick-ass n'a été
monstrueux france et 5e segpa 1 cuil
j'avais l'impression que c'était bon
puisque jordan prend 17 il faut prendre
trois mais j'ai dû rater un truc france
et 5
les sirops prend il n'y a pas fait
changer vraiment la fin il ya food et 5
c'est ça la pointe mais il verra une
pièce m'en fou prend
pourquoi n'a pas pu dans le cadre
d'abord à y avait d'apprendre les 6
quant aux visiteurs ils prendront décide
d'abord parce que sinon il y avait des
primes à nancy qu'est ce que c'est que
ça attends c'est quoi le bilan la france
2 a battu pas faire d'ahmed de tout et
de tout ce que j'avais bien dams et 8 3
h cette dame f5 g6 damev 6 et je vois
pas de maths d'alger 2,3 g 4 h 5 3 g 5 4
nadal et dames projetteront approche 3 3
n'est pas de match et minent son sort
c'est ouf
ouais c'est complètement rouge est en
est ce que kg cat et un coup à nant kg
qu'à trois points je crois que tu
l'entends la finale était qu'à mieux
super défenseur brême et de duda domine
complètement en fait le match 10 et 5 g
5 il laisse le quatrième venir même si
j'aurais fait si il alors qu'on échec
tour c'est celle déjà c'est très bizarre
g5y et mieux mais j'espère que c'est pas
une juste une fois il faut juste le
ranger si ce moment c'est pas con enfin
attentifs à prendre cali price est
surtout mais qu'il y avait des preuves 7
avec id détourbet 5 je te fais souk
aient procédé si je vais pas la perdre
est ce que tu vas être c'est avec les
blancs tu veux la gagner un tour b6
master pro à six cavaliers 4 vous qui
avait lieu 4 et là tu prends tu veux la
gagne 3 secondes on n'a aucun mobilier
on part comme si de rien n'était ils ont
deux secondes ce cas on a gagné cinq
tours à 7 ça va faire très très mal la
carrière cinq tours à cette année encore
cavaliers bull tour g7
je pense qu'il va la perdre ça c'est
très bien joué menaces etc et aussi de
ne pas y avait eu 4 c'est bien vu holt
avait promis s'est activée oui mais
attention il est pas mal aux siens ouais
ouais mais du coup le talent heures le
roi était faible c'est moins clair
là il a il a dit un club ce qui joue
vite à temps arrive à mettre le carré y
en a quatre qui a aidé et juan mata
s'est tendue et ce qui va réussir à deux
secondes 6
franchement je suis très content du
niveau qu'on veut c'est impressionnant
arcari les c3 et c3 il eut à calais tour
s'élancera la faim et la finale depuis
on gagne il prend la casse chili est
même temps pour la callas pour la hâte
en complètement gagnant ouais ok tu pars
là bas tu sors du quart et tu rentres
dès qu'ils joueront dans re5
oui c'est à rodez qui ferait non mais
attends il y en a des nuls des comme ça
comment moi c'est simple c'est fini
c'est pas des comme ça savait que là
c'est fini mais je trouvais que c'était
plus simple de juste faire f 4 puis on
prend et de faire les pions doublé a été
plus simple à gagner non rien n'a pas de
nom mais je vois ce que tu veux y aller
comme en l'annulant fait c'est quand à
a3 b4 contrat si ça et comment il y en a
une qui est nul un peu bizarre où
intuitivement elle paraît gagnante
bah franchement impressionnant mais pas
rentrer à cela un peu vos lui donc il
revient dans cette ligne est la dernière
force tous les éléments il a joué à
schiste il a pas sortir ce taux a changé
cette fois pas et c'est une opération
plus aal.l d'amway et arrive à le garder
moi je vois pas enfin j'ai vu la bande
j'ouvre pas laquelle il y en a une qui
est bizarre mais c'est pas celle là donc
là il ya un truc instructif pour les
gens les blondes sont pas obligés de
jouer trois ici parce que kg 4 taureaux
2 il ya plus le plan watch huit
cavaliers à chis qui a qu'un pion à
schiste voilà l'énorme perdu en tendant
à 6 500 que ça a été inventé par un
grand succès et b3 c'est ce qu'a
recommandé dans le vif de dix pages des
partis là dans un match nba gris tchouk
combes et saint caprais coupe du monde
ouais quand même à gagner je pense à des
percées de dire ça ça change je sais
qu'il que je peux comprendre mais je
croirais géant via plusieurs parties
dans cette ligne mais cette idée b3
c'était leurs recommandations des chefs
dans son histoire italienne et je sais
duda son entraîneur ni beaucoup de
livres ce qui est un peu vide jarek oued
échec il y est grave par exemple il a
gagné plusieurs parties avec le livre de
demuth se recueillir 3 et 4 sont arrêtés
d'ailleurs il avait battu groupe
travaille pas la partie un peu dingue
bekkat j'ai eu cinq travaillent pas ce
truc keller 3 des 5 c 4 des cas de bkc
l'arrêt qu'il avait juste réciter la
prépa du livre de deux minutes mais
c'était un gros joueur d'el chef non il
était quoi il était top 50 mondial était
quoi arrêter 26 57
à l'époque c'était quoi c'était j'étais
pas mal l'om non je conçois quitté sur
un ace que non fort d'issy faut toujours
se méfier des deux caps comprend des
projets 3d cause du clonage
mais il faut aussi se méfier parce que
près des cinq ans précisant que sa
marque pas toujours donc là j'aurais
tendance à bien aimer les noix un an
qu'il veut taper le cuir de 5
donc est-ce que cat et un coup ici on
dirait pas qu'il défend est ce qu'on
attend c'est la dernière c'est peut-être
la dernière prime s'ils sont revient à
4-4 quand même ce sera un poil contre le
cours du match un 2-2 les amendements
mais ouais c'est un niveau très proche
un fou prend gays kev' s'en réjouit le
truc c'est que ce refrain qui reprend
ses droits dont ils forcent puis on
prend et il va faire re cat et va jouer
la structure est ce que je peux pas je
vous prends juste
ben ça marche ouais ça sent je vais
rebondir là dessus l'info sekkat échecs
magnus quai
la toile afin d'avoir essayé d'avoir
entre ces 5 mai dans ça que j'arrive pas
le far marche mais puis on prend ta pas
trop envie quand même de base à prendre
le cadre vide ce come back a directement
sauf qu'à monter le niveau de jeu est là
il ya du fou prend h troc un nom qui est
des quatre proches pensent ça se regarde
ça la z4 parce que ouais cas des quatre
provinces je crois que l'on prend h
trois dames g3 tous rêvent de sa ferme
at jaillir ça va mal mais matin marche
aussi mais juste ou alors se trouve vous
prend 1,3 faudra jouer d'un machin qui
n'ont rien à voir ici
elle ressent pas trop hein tu commences
à partir là dedans effet cash devrait ce
que j'allais dire mais ça part en coin
que sur fonds propres 3
il comprend h3 il veut jouer un coup il
à machin ou d'un machin et attaques des
cinq îles quand tu fais d'alger 3g
taureau de damages 5 me semble qu il
prend un temps médian ya pas un danger
trop en arrière j'aurais un chercheur de
me2 à titre why avoue prendre des cinq
par la wii mais jara prénom je le fais
je peux pas donc ils apprendront ces six
pions qui veut faire c'est 4 ou quoi cet
effet il faut faire gaffe aussi à des
coups de fouet genre tous rêvent de
prise d'un point g et tours fc zurich
3-2 du fou g4g catherine adam rennes 3-2
et peut-être une menace d'ailleurs ça
hyper chaud gars ne dominons jusqu'où je
peux pas penser les cochons idc football
il veut jouer ces quatre attaqué à 5
mine de rien mais il menace rien sur un
coup comme tous réussissent
6 parce que l'on à un pion prend la
mouche et trois à la dame jeux d'eau
cannes mais tu fais quoi tu fais tour
justice d'abord ça marchera peloton non
j'ai trois dames jets d'objets 4g est
une menace on est de fous aussi ses
quatre roues bon y'a plein de plus ces
quatre à québec est donc c4 et becketts
en mettant d'ailleurs et les catins ok
donc la c4
manas la dame c'est ce à quoi je vais
pas partir en g3 je pense qu'il veut je
veux qu'ils aient la faim dans tous les
cas ah non après la cage et 4 dames g3
je te fais ces quatre monnaies quebéc as
tu te prend au moins un champion à
passer sur ces quatre québec il faut
prendre d'apprentis faisait 25 ans et je
préfère d'abord 5 adam ces cinq
personnages passâmes c5v pas trop mais
ça veut dire sur ces quatre ils
voulaient jockey et ses 3 500 milles
elle avait ainsi replacé défend le pion
il veut jouer c'est donc après il peut
aussi jouer dams et 5 c 4 cavaliers
si c'est la dame g5 des fois un sapin
mais non commencés par qualifier c'est
pas idiot d'ailleurs les bazars elle est
bien ça pas besoin de larmes nasri à
l'époque jacques henry ok donc qu'est-ce
qu'il veut kg capture encore laquelle
gic est peut être une menace pour les
veuves noires parce que prise vous prend
et cavalli a faim on a marché d'un match
4 il ya du tout rêve de f1 mais bon lors
des 8 es fou c'est très fausse e3
oui les cannelures du tout répond quand
même fait recaler gkp n'y avait qu'un
maillage 5 aussi con lavage des cas
s'agirait pas pensé une seconde mais il
veut se créer un pion passé à pour avoir
des magouilles pour faire diversion
diversion et c'est bien ce genre de truc
tu essaies mais tu regardes que l'autre
côté tu oublie ça il est capable de
faire fois à cinq pour revenir un an ces
six pouces et 7 pour faire foi mais il
faut à saint qui fait tord à vii
probablement autour un la tour axa temps
plus frais partout bref 8,1
non mais c'est le genre de coup faut à 5
ans et tendance à vouloir faire ces
systèmes pos c'est une grosse connerie
parce que le four vient ans et 7 ans et
de quatre et c'est pas clair du tout
qu'on soit même mais bon tu x 5 ta juste
apparaît cette idée était bénie avec les
non enfouis ou alors 40 45 secondes
comptent deux minutes tard il vous prend
ta tut tut tut tut l'achetons fou et
débarrasse de ce cavalier ou ce 3 kg
caton très court en fait j'ai pas
compris
j'attaque e3g relance avec les deux
bouts la remarque est fou c'est 4 kg 4g
aussi car il a fait un an mais j'ai
damage 14 de métro m2 c'est une food et
200 nous son idée c'est kg capteurs f1
bref au g4 c'est bien joué du coup car
il y prend cavaliers prend il va
attaquer les cases noires autour du roi
my secret jusqu'à tours on est fou un
indu en 3,4 secondes rsa sera la
dernière partie mathieu de la cadence
donc d'un match 4 d'un match car je vais
pas la défense désolé si j'ai trois
dames de la solution à ces tristes un
vrai on est d'accord
peut-être qu'il ya tour f3 la fin
lafarge et 3 soit 3,5 ou
ou juste d'un match 4 au pire à parer au
pire tu tu es à cinq secondes contre lui
devant un faux pas peut choquer faut
qu'il fasse gaffe parce que si toutes
les tours s'échangent le pion à un lien
d'autant plus fort daniel points 4 qui
peut très bien je ressemble peut-être
fallait juste et changé d'âme je vais
dire et faire qu'ils avaient lieu cinq
ans fait mais pas s'embêter avec ça ça a
l'air quand même bien gagnant mais oui
c'est vrai mais bon ça regarde on te
reprends droit prend et l'europe est
saif ont eu deux effets rats 5 à 6 après
tu faire car les h2k relief 3 c est ce
que tu peux garder la tour ah oui tu
veux te faire ton blog est parfaitement
balisé c'était tout reprend en droit
prend carénage droit deux cavaliers f3
avec qui des dames des huit dames
détroit qui avaient des âges de re2 tu
faisais quoi car il ya trois fait-on
points qui avale jouer avec cette idée
là qui a l'air hyper forte
ouais mais je te fais à 5 dans des trois
jeux
waouh ça c'est très bien de la j'ai vu
un cavalier ou 5 et d'amérique est à me
cattoir
mais bon h5 g6 et dames c4 il veut faire
d'un match 4
comment se déséchouer et damages case le
royal ranches ça c'est certain car et
qui arriveront dès 3 adam f1 quel point
ces cut
ouais voilà il ya même du tueur et du
dam des trois pions tranquille prend 1,5
et gagner mais non c'est bien le whip
rang à 5 la non juste island ou pas il
faut faire quelque 3,5 puis dam des
trois c'est ce que c'est chiant et
gagnez peut-être non
très perdu autant non mais bon il
aurifère d'amd c'est 3 bougez total de
13,1 bouche d'un procès cette statue
maasdam b6 bon le pion c'est peut être
très fort et non gagnant 4 4 j'ai envie
de te dire fin fin de fin de segments
incroyable côté wesley wade me sens
qu'il n'a pas monté niveau de doc
commencé à craquer un peu lassé salle
d'avancé surtout il est beaucoup mieux
et il perd donc ça change tout s'est il
pas sa casquette à 5,2 s'est passé à 4,3
maintenant il ya 4 4 c'est un premier
tournant du match en ligue 1 ça doit
être tournant du match et sow est ce que
tu penses qu'à pouvoir maintenir ce
niveau de jeu maintenant toulon est ce
qu'il va faire comme à 12 soit europe va
faire un peu le lourd il bat tous genres
il respecte
non mais faut aussi mettre dans le
contact us était à 81 matches suspects
est plus fort et tu te contre tu gaming
et nice 1 0 l'autre jour c'est ça ouais
non pas de se déconcentrer on l'a tous
fait un bond après c'est ce que vous
disiez aussi avant-hier c'est qu'un mec
comme naka il veut mettre un zéro mais
ouais non mais bon après c'est une
question est ce que est ce que sow va
pouvoir
tui là il a une nouvelle à ceux qui ont
soufflé ce qui va réussir à le maintenir
ou pas est ce qu'il faudrait pas faire
1h30 de 5% pour être sûr encore non
franchement très bonne fin est-ce que
korn est ce son binôme n'a d'yeux ça
marche aussi un vrai j'aurais perso
j'aurais juste enlever la section bull
est en fait on a trop d'importance il ya
trop de bulles est je trouve dans ces
matchs et à non mais moi je vais penser
à un truc mais ça peut être content de
commencer par le bullet pour que l'un
portant sur l'étal d'un parti non plus
ouais mais après le problème c'est que
ouais
au niveau du système nerveux commencer
par dubuffet ça que c'est violent tu
peux tu peux vite te retrouver dans un
truc où il ya plus d'importance à la fin
quoi est ce que je peux faire une mini
pause ou pas vas-y vas-y ça en prend un
coup en bas à 40 je pense aux quais bas
tout de suite à l'essai matière la pause
mais oui non le prêt mission et le
bullet sait que le match soit
mathématiquement finit bien trop tôt et
on ne serait pas bien sûr ce qui serait
un vrai problème ne pas être bien sûr
est très problématique les amis
mais il n'aura mis que 15 minutes de
boulettes peut-être de bullet
les come back sur le bullet ça existe et
bien en réalité
ouais ça peut dans certains matchs ça
peut exister ça peut parfois être le cas
mais c'est rarissime
souvent ça confirme plus la dynamique du
match à moins qu un peu comme un doux
dakar ouanna qui est un droit qui soit
vraiment moins fort en bullet
on trouve tablette c'est trois ou cinq
parties pour trancher en cas d'égalité
on va dire que c'est je mettrai 15
minutes 15 minutes ça fait vrai en gros
cinq partis c'est vraiment si un match
serré à deux points d'écart pour que
pour que tu es une chance de revenir ou
quoi mais c'est je trouve que neuf
parties de bullet autant que 5 + 1 s'est
un peu trop perso
le billet ça va vraiment être quelque
chose qui départage plus à la fin
qu'autre chose hein
pourrais tu demandes à bach y chez les
olives et laissera aux disposer les
dédicaces et de champion sur
possiblement une dédicace de maxime je
crois plus que ce soit possible il est
reparti et l'olivier il sera en débutant
en début de mois brel et bullet c'est
plus des paiements je trouve que donner
autant d'importance au but lettre
qu'aurait ce c'est un peu c'est un peu
dommage choix j'aurais bien qu'ils aient
encore une heure de trois plus ça on
voit qu'il est le meilleur trouve la
demi-heure de bull est en fait elle est
vraiment vrai que soit dix minutes 15
minutes
et merci à hulu crise ton pour le sable
merci à toi voyez en plus en plus la
cadence en soi et blizzard pourrait
peut-être juste dix minutes 2 1 + 1 2 1
+ 0 ou même six minutes d'un + 0 ou 4
parties ou vraiment quelque chose de
deux courts quoi
quelque chose de vraiment très court
pour départager quoi vous ici à 12.6 à
un ou deux points d'écart pour faire ok
pour faire jouer sur une autre cadence
mais pas plus
après c'est ma vision du truc hein on
est pas on n'est pas obligé tous est
d'accord mais je trouve que des autant
d'importance aux bulles est qu avec eux
qu'au reste c'est c'est un peu trop
voilà tout
la fnac est assez d'accord mais après
monde est critiquée à la pensée unique
wen
bah je sais pas trop pourquoi ils font
ça comme ça mais écoutez c'est comme ça
ça favorise n'a qu'à en attendant et
c'est ça l'important
et c'est ça l'important les amis
c'est que ça favorise notre naka
saori ce pas aussi mvl non je pense pas
que faire beaucoup de bullet ça favorise
ça favorise mvl non mais le truc c'est
qu'on a on a de très belles parties dans
5 + 1 en trois puissants aussi et c'est
dommage que ça se finit sur un truc sur
un truc un peu voilà enfin
c'est comme ça
je sens pas une bulle à toi du coup
c'est une carence bizarre
non c'est pas une question ne pas aimer
le bullet moi j'aime bien au contraire
mais sur un match aussi long le fait que
ce soit ça qu'ils soient déterminants je
trouve ça un peu dommage c'est plus ça
le truc que 5 + 1 et 3 + 1 c'est la même
importance pourquoi pas à la rigueur
mais trois qu'un plus un et la même
importance que les deux autres voire
même un peu plus c'est un peu dommage
voilà il faudrait deux heures et demie
de 5 + 1 2 heure de 2,3 plus sain et une
demi-heure de bullet
après c'est mon point de vue un c'est
pas la science infuse c'est comme ça que
je vois les choses mais si c'est comme
ça c'est que les gens doivent préférer
comme ça
gross avait envie de terminale et celui
qui fait le meilleur temps dernier
tournant mais je sais pas assez moi je
trouve ça bizarre mais après c'est
bizarre mais il ya sur un côté
dramatique qui peut être sympa mais du
coup pourquoi t'es pas obligée d'en
mettre neuf pour ce soit dramatique si
tu en mets 4 c'est pareil oui c'est un
peu trop long d'accord ben moi je
raccourcis d'areva aussi de raccourcir
et tout mais en fait j'ai re si je
devais raccourcir un seul truc sera
curseur est le bullet vous exagérez un
peu quand on a un match de fou on est
bien content ah ouais mais pas ta plus
d'intensité 6 à moins de parti aussi
en réalité seule une lueur de ce prime
de chrome
mais d'ailleurs ça j'aimerais bien voir
des compétitions de trucs d'exo et on a
eu il y en a eu déjà arrivé mais ça n'a
pas très bien marché mais j'ai vu il y
avait un grec était monstreux est abattu
comme ils s'appellent là l'américain
robson et la banque ses cinq as encore
une souligner quelles sont ses peines
ouf les cadres qui avaient eu quand même
des cut
non c'est pas ni triste jamais je
connaissais pas madame séduit sans doute
c'était peu la marine et des corrections
résolution d'études ça existe aussi un
je crois c'est pas de problème là c'est
d'études encore différent
c'est bien là où le polonais champion du
monde toujours là casper kurun ému style
très bon à rien mon pote polonais
d'ailleurs bosnie il est dans l'équipe
en fait ils gagnent à thézan il ya
plusieurs sections ouais ok donc il a ça
c'est pas juste pourri pour les noirs
d'après moi dans le souvenir oui mais tu
as l'impression que tu vas te prendre
foot est roi fou b2g quatre oies qui
traîne un peu en maître sur faut
détruire mon avis veut laisser la
tension quelque part j'ai 4 après tu
peux bien sûr mettre le four b2 faire
juste quand même la jouer grand roque
sais pas ouais il a raison il faut
qu'ils jouent eye a pas foule y'a pas
des fous des solutions intercim que ça
tu perds la partie avec n'ont donc cinq
ouvertures chaussettes comme rouge voilà
c'est vraiment qatar bouger les cathos
hamas un g4 qui est moment est ce qu'il
va dire que les autres sur la rue que
j'utilise à s'enfoncer enfants de finir
leur assiette c'est terrible c'est
terrible des enfants qui veulent pas
manger jusqu'à la fin et a des problèmes
avec la petite hacker négo pour manger
manger manger ouais ouais elle veut pas
le biberon c'est un petit progrès mais
non ça mange pas beaucoup mais bon ça se
passe honnêtement ça se passe beaucoup
mieux la crèche ça se passe mieux
y'a juste dors pas bien mais à part ça
ça va c'est un petit problème à me
lasser
j'exagère en disant que c'est un
avantage décisif pour les blancs mais je
pense que c'est si tu joues bien avec
les plans c'est juste vraiment finir en
gros pour résumer s'il y avait le rock
ça serait un peu mieux pour les blancs
parce qu'on jouerait fou des 3rocs f4
les blancs et plus de perspectives ou
faisait 5 ce que tu veux
et c'est un plan que ce droit est en
fuite 4 tu vas partir là bas tu menaces
f5 et g3 en plus qu'il ya plus de cases
compromis 5 pouces et quatre menaces
aussi donc là qu'elle soit f5 pour
écraser au cul on prend un air sain pur
jus de gagner le clan des cadres ou
d'ailleurs qui avait produit 1,5 to b 2
qui reprend les quatre h3g train de dire
tu peux aussi laissé attention parce que
puis on trouve quatre cavaliers prends
ça va être développé où je me fous
prendre c'est terrible des images
terribles et l'aso qui commence à faire
mal ainsi lengagne troisième lille fait
la grimace wesley il n'a pas changé les
kamas sur l'autre après les faits il a
joué un peu la naca là c'est quoi cette
grimace de merde c'est pas et h3 il est
pas contente du coup mais c'est vrai car
je crois en fait ça semble rien faire en
fait c'est moi il avait sans doute un
truc qui l'a vu après que nous on n'a
toujours pas vu ou attaquer cette menace
américaine bien logique faut aussi s'il
profite du fait qu'ils aient pu être 5 6
la france et quatre voix lui ça c'est un
peu chez qui sait qu'il a fait ça
ensemble jusque tendre 8 puis on prend
1,5 to b de savoir d'étalement riley
peut-être des trois que du détroit donc
il faut c'est un truc c'est l'américain
bausch et la tête je ne sais pas mais je
crois c'était vraiment achraf usé quatre
c'était vraiment pas les bons coups il a
apprêté quand même bien même f5 français
que dan franck et sept dessins et de
lettres mais n'a pas envie de faire ça
tu étais tellement mieux avant que
tapant peut-être food et troyes et tours
à deux laissez pas à tour à deux c6 r à
deux tours b 2 juste à tomber des têtes
fou des trois un peu triste mais ok t'es
juste mieux quand même
c'est ce qui fait tour à deux tours b de
joie je vois pas le life 5
qu'est-ce que je rate
non mais c'est juste une pièce ouais
rien rater dans la tête
qu'est-ce que tu ailles très beaux
vêtements tout d'un de france et 4 où
une minute
alors là je pense que quand tu as quant
à ce cas de figure avec les noirs faut
jouer mais pour se calmer
oui on put commencer la tête mais c'est
pas facile à faire un faux pas s'énerver
ok tu sais que tu vas la paire zhu zhu
quelques coups pour souffler pour pas
recommencer tout de suite tu as khroub
et 5e c4 c4 tout de suite voilà tu dois
être dire jean christophe serre les
dents ne t'énerve pas il ya une nouvelle
partie qui reprend nantes va dire ça
mais ça arrive bien perdre on vous prend
aux six de reprendre cette histoire
prend 1,6 terminez termine à dos bon
trois d'affilée la gamme
donc là il joue comment lui joue à
piolenc à eux deux ils jouent rarement
avec grand ni donc il va il doit pas vu
le truc à la mode
après ils ont un truc à la mode concours
c'est très con parce qu'il est tellement
meilleur appareil contient lui dit que
les dix doigts si on ne fait pas ça jean
christophe ne fait surtout pas ça parce
que ça qui doit il doit absolument se
calment et jean-christophe ok ça c'est
le son très riche les blancs rongeurs r3
quand les blancs rouges 9 3 et 9 ans je
sais 5
l'udc avait des valeurs f4 ou g3 wave 4
c'est plutôt la mode mais il faut rock
est d'abord même dame ce2 ce bilan alors
pourquoi à six parce qu'ils jouent ces
cinq ans passant de calais b 5e et rock
vous prend h de marche ou pas peut-être
la phase 3
des 600 le fond bessette non il veut
juste se sentent je pense que le maroc
se sent que tu as lu ces quatre défauts
toujours très bien préparés
l'idée c'est que c'est ça qui va prendre
deux fois et je pinzolo non mais du coup
quelle est cette sécu logique pour
pouvoir prendre du cahier ok je pense je
fais rock c'est simple je prends deux
fois je mets le cas bien des cats
je laisse mon show case blanche comme
tout à l'heure aux prises christophe
gaussin les prises puisque les d4 on le
prend en fait repris ce prix de france
prise free souhaite 5 à 42 4 je pense et
vous savez tout repenser 8 qu'est tombé
1 ça a du sens il vous faut être
simplement
donc c'est une structure type pas neuf
sites un peu n'importe quoi la panne est
à cette structure ci et là il ya le fou
qui vient soit 5 qui n'importe quoi il
est capable de dicter ce que je note
c'est catastrophe prend vous prend et
apoel cinq tours but qui va arriver ça
ouais c'est demain matin que ça va être
terminé
mais là ça va être terrible ça peut
faire ça veut faire 4-0
quel d'affilée à auxerre on a peut-être
chanter trop vite
en fait au moment au moment où on
pensait que duda avait été bien entré
dans son match j'ai fait un bon début de
match et ils sont déconnectés terrible
qui est déconnecté brest et se
déconnecter tension il est encore
connectés à internet mais mes beug beug
serveurs chess comme ça peut être
terrible pour wesley brown mais aussi
persuadé qu en matière là ça y est là je
suis content encore un match qui peut
jouer sur la connexion à nancy les
reconnecter terrible
taryn mathieu mais du coup c'est 2 à 4
50 secondes web à duda il aurait pu
aller plus vite quoi il aurait pu
essayer de jouer la déco donc j'étais en
train de me dire ce qu'ils pouvaient pas
ici de 4 2 des 4 guns of dingue qu'elle
prend 1,4 calais prend des cinq mais j'y
croyais tellement pas les champions de
france je voulais je me fous de dieu 5
mais bon j'ai 4 - contrôle fouet pts 5
ils le jeu kéhi g 3 pts et dockers cat
et moi je suis mais bon il peut bannon
g520 sera jamais une baisse assez bien
joué qui avait plongé 4 ça c'est les
coups qu'on aime mathieu qui on prend un
coup franc non dans mes choix d'un match
4 encore plus fort
on aime si ça marche c'est tellement
encore mathieu x 3 qui arrive damache
dans la froide alger 2 est ce que je
faisais qu'elle prend des 5 et surtout
estrada marche pas c'est quoi le bail de
maths
non moi je voulais je kf4 mais tu
prenais damage points on ne va pas faire
très attention mais il n'y voit rien
tout en étant pollen tout en étant
polonais magie bon podium
bon ça aurait dû être 5,2 au niveau des
positions dont il ya 6 4 inversez ali
change ok ayvaz je la vends un petit
père bordel c'est 5
ça c'est bien je n'ai d'ailleurs c'est
pas la plus bordel cela il ya pire
l'assistante tout de suite mais mathieu
c'est là encore la fois arrêter
l'hémorragie un petit nul et si c'est
pas déjà trompé non mais tu peux pas
être tu peux pas tout le temps de
tromper quand même pas possible tu crois
que c'est encore trompé m'a simplement
pas s'arrêter bien c'est pas
peut-être il a besoin d'un truc simple
donc c'est pas mal de jus un truc comme
ça mais ça pas les règles non c'est bon
pour les blancs mais après quelques
renseignements par curiosité vous jouer
instinctivement il ya beaucoup
d'apprentissage 1 il ya beaucoup
d'apprentissage bouquin il ya les deux
cas et mettront ça va être dégueulasse
et un pour les manchots vous faut à
chaque fois sombre et d'or tu gardes
tellement toutes tes options t souple
aujourd'hui elle fait qu'elle aimait
trop bas je me bouge et le foot yukon
peut-être qu'à ip3 qui est des quatre
pieds métro à ce que j'ai dit mais cela
ne cessera il veut provoquer qui avait
prend des trois c'est bien joué
non il est pas content il fait des
signes de tête hamilton il a peut-être
des déconnexions terrible pour lui aller
les serveurs de chasse comme qui pour
une fois sont en train de jouer contre
les joueurs américains
ça fait plaisir quand même mathieu de
retrouver des problèmes si c'est pour ça
qu'il parle tout seul là ouais ouais non
mais je sais pas je sens que tu as là
qu'il a un qui s'y fait non mais à
quelque chose qui va pas ça vient pas
des coûts la ja n en ya quelque chose
qui va pas avec à chaque sens qui est
assez duda qui réfléchit c'est hyper
bizarre il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas ou est ce les jeux les rarement vu
aussi expressif
là il fait des petites têtes bizarre
mais d'ailleurs pas chauve qui n'a pas
sommeil non non c'est pour ça que je
n'avais pas l'impression que c'est
l'impression que j'ai l'impression qu'il
essaie de cliquer sur moi j'ai une
deuxième caméra de sécurité où il fait
des trucs avec sans moi vous avez
l'impression qu'il ya quelque chose qui
le lie les élèves les auvergnats paquet
ici cd4 ici 15
adapté de quatre attaques et au delà
mais un truc qui avait l'air de pas vous
sa connexion quoi il n' a rien truqués
l'extérieur qui l'énervent en fait je
crois
bon je sais pas exactement il en train
de chanter le pont non mais regardez
truc de côté jusqu'à mi-août a vu la
photo de lui derrière quand il joue à
l'écran il met la fenêtre en petit tu
avais vu ce que j'ai vu c'est vrai c'est
le moi d'ailleurs sur mon ordi je trouve
quand je sois pièces comme celle de
l'écran un échiquier beaucoup trop bon
là elle lui met un petit verre mais
c'est ça notre jeune homme de paille
maxime qui c'est terrible il chante à la
tête qui il devait encore plus américain
de melaka et b3 commenté galli j'en ai
fait d'armes problème 6 tours cedex
histoire ce set
madame bref si j'aurais fait instants
après j'y vais je tombais 8 qui valait 8
3 et fuite
il s'en sort en face et on va la jouer
un risque élevé les huit sort ou pas
c'est petrosyan qui le spam a foulé 5
c'est bien joué ça c'est bien joué
empêche cavaliers 8 et prépare qui avait
trois cas et c5
key4it galice pas vraiment non 6
ouais ça paraît logique de faire raciste
si tu perds mais au moins tu adoptes est
pas là mais regarde le temps ces huit
c'est possible ou pas toronto soutient
qu'il est fin des cat way avec vous ces
4 qui arrive après connaissant l'homme
qui peut aussi prendre des jokers 3 ça
reste confiant qu'on va te la jouer mais
bon elle est nulle ça c'est nul mais bon
c'est que le temps une 30 contre 30
donc si c'est comme à chaque fois qu'il
ya des connexions et les mines dame en
salle pour nevers cette déconnexion je
peux aider quelque chose qui n'allait
pas sur son écran c'est sûr peut-être y
avoue changer de musique peut-être
qu'ils jouent de la musique sur son ordi
qui changer de morceau et quitterait pas
le morceau qui voulait c'est aussi
possible ou des fois des mises à jour
qui sauvent votre guide teneur antivirus
naïve à jauger 4,6 g 4 kms et si je
pense qu'il le prince ne s'est pas
empêché qu'ils avaient f5 mémoire rb5
qui sait si cette fois-ci même
s'affaiblissant ouais mais on a gagné
quelque chose avec les noms d'un à bagré
blanc barentin donc plus sur la case
blanche puis on assistera voir mon fils
après le bessin qui peut le faire quand
il veut peut-être cavalière qui a et c 3
f 4 ans qu'il veut jouer fc nantes 4 1
bon même si day bon je pense que ça il
va tenir là je crois que de dallas après
un bon set up
ce qui joue le fou à calquer qui repart
sur six c'est d'autre on a un sens pour
eux 4 puis on comprend qu'il va les
prendre 5 3 6 7 6 nadal se jouer ah
ouais c'est une sorte de ce feuilleton
moi je crois qu'ici si j'ai un casier
simplement
tu as tellement ses descendants de
huguenots b5
là encore c'est bien joué je raconterai
bien joué les cinq auraient jamais non
plus parce que c'est très bien je ne
sais pas est-ce que ça gagne je sais pas
mais dans l'idée pour faire pour donner
un choix et juin
il trouve une idée il n'ya pas s kg 6
krk peut pas être une idée je lui dirai
sont pas faire fou à lui d'ici qu'est ce
que je ferais kg 6 me la jouer avec le
gain des noirs mais c'est peut-être faut
juste que je te propose était plus
pratique et prend 5 pouces et quatre ris
d'agneau les c4 est ce que tu peux
tenter ta chance
c'était chaud
il a attiré le cavale manoeuvre 3 ou
éprise prises qui est franchement je
comprend rien à la réflexion mais on est
tous des calices et tu peux patentés qui
c'est quatre ici moi ses lettres je
comprends rien en fait
ah oui avec trois horaires pardon mais
noires sont un peu des cendre preuve 3g
h 4 c'est super ouais h4 failli pousser
avec deux secondes à stopper
l'hémorragie
fini les tétons morceau donc c'est là
l'important
il repart dans ses lignes où il connaît
rien ça fait plaisir
fait à 3 d'abord est à l'heure et la
prise prises à trois mais c'est bon là
ils ont sept reprises ces cinq là dame
de revenir sur cette voie là il ya
plusieurs pouilles kf2 kf3
qui est de ses plus dans son style donc
la dame c'est cette idée cette tour des
huit des cinq autour des 85 points noirs
mais aussi b6 aussi que le x 6 or c'est
le cou à la mode démentait la jeunesse a
besoin d'en avoir gagné terrible et
gagnent leur mauvais mais des sucres m
comment il faut jouer je crois qu'ici il
ya un truc à ce troll commence à me
faire bizarre ils encaissent ici ce qui
est à cinq je crois mais les blondes le
cidj aux c4
bon ça mange et un tumulte au rang des 8
tu fais 5
c'est chaud a pris du cavaliere demain
soir c'est différent de ces c'est mieux
de ce qu'il est de ce qu il a joué avant
c'est dans ce cas la connais moins bien
ce package ou quoi à 2-5 nassau simple
c'est ça il se prend du coup dans damas
quatre peut-être mais d'un magasin
blizzard annonce apprise avec le carré
les en d4
après peut-être une raison à ces îles et
les langes trop ville et les moules mais
d'un mike catt d'un mac est 5e mais des
racques tu peux toujours accueillera
tout pc dupliquer semble alors c'est les
positions qui sont sans doute
ok pour l'allemand mais il faut faire
gaffe des fois au four b2 ces fameux
jeux sur les cases noires qui pointe on
ne saute pas aux yeux
non en fait ça peut arriver vite ans on
nous demande on craque
qu'est ce que la pâte c'est ça
j'hallucine le pad c'est quand t'as pas
de tes pas échec
t'as pas de coûts légaux
à huit ce d'un me de après une minute ou
légale d'ailleurs peut-être comme t'as
pas un coup les games lego
non sincèrement ce n'est pas pas de coup
légal je pense que ça t'as pas besoin
d'avoir plusieurs palais gotha pas de
coup légal j'ai hésité entre les deux
hommes ouais mais je pense c'est plutôt
légal non le p5 très bien joué pendant
30 ans je me suis pas sûr que l'on prend
dalmat 5 et les finales robes sont sains
et donc ses 5 5e ce sont des négociants
se soudent d'un inspecteur juste que
c'est 0-0 est un singulier en français
tu dois y aura pas de coup légal ouais
ben joue bien on n'a pas des coûts
légaux mais j'ai dit on à pas d'écouler
le nom de grenat pas de la patte de tous
les cas l'un pour pour être pour être
précis si tu as un coup légal en fait tu
peux jouer donc quand tu dis on n'a pas
de coûts légaux
oui c'est une faute c'est l'objectif des
coûts légaux et alors que c'est un coup
légal
c'est terrible bon je me couchais on
fiche complètement en fait mais mais du
coup là les noirs sont pas mal non il a
réussi à bloquer des quatre et c5 sur
carré noir chaussures cannois c'est ça
va demander du travail de nouveaux
auxquels il assurent fou pranger de il
veut faire quoi bas des 5 je pense vous
prend et angers 3 ouais ouais c'est bien
gelé sa hutte orages 3 h 20 qu'est ce
que c'est une mélodie en dessin d'après
ce qu'on peut jouer des 51 mais non
trois cavaliers seront sûrs qu'elle
prend à ces deux interdits qui a aidé 5
ce qui à damas d'ailleurs est un coup en
fait ouais mais ce qui prouve que dobbs
dans le bon coup ouais mais évidemment
bien waouh bien joué mais il veut torje
cinq tours j'ai six mois mais tu fais
torje trois tonneaux et du coup
peut-être fait sauvage 5 tu protèges
trompions améliorée des cinq par les
rivages autour de but en fait durant
l'hymne est un vrai bien faire ça et ça
peut-être je me demandais si phocéen
pourrait être un coup pour changer de
diagonale mais tu en prends des câbles
de revenir comme ça il va sur les cases
noires donc d'anarchistes peut être un
coût deux fois
du coup ils empêchent paroisse fuite est
fou c'est 2 il va je fous d un fleuve 3
ça si le doodle qu'on connaît manoeuvre
au début j'ai plein de manoeuvre ils
rendaient fous le mec il comprenait rien
jamais il faut d un mois the trois ans
qui a choisi le mag du couloir sait
jamais il n'y a pas de tanger 5 qui
pourrait être une idée je pense qu'il
veut mettre la tour angers 5 dont
jacques atlan à la mie câline ses seins
je pense tu vas prendre la nouveau et ce
n'est la question ne se pose pas mais
est ce que tu peux pas jouer le tour f3
d'un tour g5
ouais ouais c qui prend la nuit je pense
stratégiquement dans le match c'est par
à jouer parce que comme il domine avec
les blancs il reprend les blancs à 12h
change encore et vous oriente 5 passes
et l'enceinte requis revenus normalement
il prend 2,5 d'abord se change quoi je
sais pas voyez les parties 12 heures à
saint john
chez rogers récemment il a mis la
pression entre les vannes chez crème
liquide ailleurs qu'elle veut scinder
premier com de com beaucoup de choses
derrière sa démission
il boit tranquille mais ça après pas
dans les ouvertures est vraiment pas
suffisante pour le haut niveau tout
assez mais c'est toujours pareil c'est
que d'un côté tu dis ça prouve qu'il est
fort malade côté c'est tellement énorme
ça prouve qu'il est faible aussi dans
les salles prouve qui lui manque
il a peut-être tout le talent du monde
sauf un talent qui lui manque celui de
beaucoup travailler et malheureusement
c'est celui qui va faire la différence
tu vois c'est bien un zoom
malheureusement ce salon si tu l'as pas
tu fais quoi
quel est cet essai cicae les sept sur
les enjeux de cette 5ème qui est
incroyable c'est jean yves klein comme
magnus c'est qu'en fait ils multiplient
tellement de talents différents
j'imagine à quel point il faut être
complet je crois qu'il a surtout
énormément travaillé jeunes maintenant
il travaille mais beaucoup moins ce que
j'entends 2 il fait pas beaucoup dormi
après il a une mémoire de bouffe en aide
quant à des groupes rép on se prépare
bien je vois je vois la taille de me
ficher je vois comme mes élèves sont en
galère les fichiers de mac users pas
imaginer alors que les fichiers les
filles chic t'en vas tu es élèves à côté
de ce cas magnus à doit être mais en
fait je sais quand un peu confus travail
ils ont plusieurs fichiers d'ailleurs ça
serait marrant coming principe ils ont
un fichier qui te dit les grosses lignes
ils ont un fichier résumé il au fichier
complet est normalement si tu travailles
bien il nous faut jamais le fichier
complet c'est juste quand il est quand
il regarde la trucks en or d'ici là une
question il va voir le fichier complet
c'est pas mal comme principe ça c'est
logique je trouve ouais mais est ce que
tout le monde le fait je mange je sais
pas mais j'ai en fait si tu si je me
mettais à faire des trucs moi j'aime
bien à plusieurs affiché pour la même
chose non là sur damas un qui à tour ses
cinq jeux posé la question je sais c'est
joli quoi ces nouveaux maîtrise rare de
tenir cette pièce comme ça après tu peux
madame en effet 6
mais je commence à me dire que les noirs
sont bien non c'est très un peu vite ça
ne m'a pas tant mais mathieu d'un même
si à tout repenser mitsou bessette
mathieu qui est pas chaud aujourd'hui
[Musique]
relations surface hamas sa mort j'ai pas
leur dis donc je veux pas dire mais
terrible mathieu masoe pas c'est bon
pour chauffer sa démarche il se passe
quoi sur tour à tour à tour ses cartes
au piège et d'un cran et il empêche le
tour c'est 8 de manière à surtour c8 et
adam d adam ses huit ans à 3 gagne 10
maximum d'un musée cats écolo gains dame
b3 peut-être menace prise
cette méprise bessette à le guen il est
des rêves explique l'abbé 300 en outre
mais d'albert ier
il ya marcigny h3 dans le programme des
4 ok sur age 3 dawn 17
mais même d'amd 4 j'ai toujours pas
compris pourquoi ça gagne à ce qu'après
tu fait de repenser vite compris joseph
6 nous dff trois mois
à la fin c'est quand tu fais dans le 17
juin 4 est sûr aussi c'est une dame des
quatre et c5 nous montre comme ça c'est
pas un cadre la tournée en russie
là si tu fais si je peux je 4,4 paraît
plus logique
un caprice cela on arrive pas trop un
truc pour tuer quoi t'attendre sent
qu'il peut le tuer autour de l'ensemble
j'ai planté une découverte à l'occuper
si si si mais ça marche pas du tout aimé
b6 vous prend à lui tu prends des katja
ses huit ans la faim et à 4 c à b vite
donc je vais ses six daims me casse ça
l'agacé 6 520 sa future prendre de 6 cas
et c5 j'avais proposé mais je n'ai rien
calculé en cavale et prendre à temps
prend damas quatre terribles
ça marche ça marche ils sont tellement
forts et d'annecy ce cahier d'être
madame alors à temps il défend bien
quand même un wesley parce que
l'ammoniac voici là les blancs nous
appartient ce qu'est une pièce mais
comment c'est possible qu'ils soient
faire bouffer comme ça non mais c'est
pas sûr que ce fût encore comment tu
veux tu peux pas ramener le roi il aura
stoppé six images de tomber si ce tome 3
et 7 b 6 3 ab sat ce trop long à mettre
super tous les pions ouais alors toi je
suis très bien joué parce que je me suis
rangé sa fiche pour le parti fera si si
c'est ça je voyais pas vide et on va
essayer à faire qu'à attendre mais qui
joue pour le gard en fait la semaine tu
as réussi ce plan a tu peux pas passer
je sait manier joue pour le lien il est
simplement passé à l'aller blanc sont au
mieux pour moi je ferais f5 ici en fait
je prendrai pas le pion pour gagner
aucune reprise 3b cet institut va à dame
en fait 100 f 5 ce faire roy bessette à
y prendre à 6 1 en deux sets 6 3 3 non
j'ai 6 3 600 et comment ces paroles 3
mai ou juin
j'essaie tours fc et enlève la tour été
ménagé cette g8 c'est ce que j'allais
dire à la gagne et cavaliers f6 qui est
prompt tureia dame allait en fait il va
juste faire rager sept îles et il a trop
voulu gagner avec la pièce ouais voilà
trop bien joué à l'aller ça je peux m'en
faut avoir une mauvaise tournure
ouais elle est bien gentil dernier même
quand il a un parent quand on avait
l'impression qu'il allait la prendre
il réussira à s'en sortir quelles
parties de l'officiel un gros niveau bas
il est vraiment fort ouais c'est là tant
il était mené 4 2 depuis ses 5 victoires
2 nuls
ça s'est il vu au championnat du monde
caruana carlson cette idée est fausse et
cinq étaient introduits au niveau par
goethe choc contre il ya neuf noms mais
rien ne le suis pas je crois pour la
faillite pleine partie depuis karl
siècle et de couleurs il y en a eu
contre maxime d'ailleurs on avait
commenté ensemble ouais dame
waouh c'est de taille fait des coups en
fait j'ai des fois je me garais c'est
jouable
mais il peut pas prendre préfère c'est
simple prendre ces cinq francs
ben oui moi je pense que trois ici et
tata le type de pollution de ma news
voulait avoir un peu mieux la même même
si et des deux dispositions en fait t'es
mieux s'en être mieux en fait ouais
l'ordi mais toujours inconnue pour les
blancs et ça c'est un truc assez récent
c'est avant tout penser que comptable et
le nez d'un concept dans le sens quelle
princesse 6 dans l'es6 y est nous qui
est français 3,6 que la ceni scissionne
averse avant ou considère ce n'était
jamais très bon en fait maintenant ça va
pour sa dette égale des lignes en fait
c'est agréable sans être mieux mais
était très content de jouer ça pendant
longtemps en fait un four b3 foulée
trois jours à jouer le tempo mais c'est
tellement magique on dérive 5 fautes 6
2me b1 tricote au monarque de notre côté
at the damned y ait non mesdames maire y
avait trois tours à 2 qui est des cas de
faux prend 1,2 gomera arrêt pour éviter
d'être prise usb cote
il ya aussi adam ici cheville franck
attend ça gagne pas poussé quatre ans et
gagné parce a poussé quatre pour ton
bouge
gb 3 je peux le temps de nous quand je
checke alors dit enfin une fois que je
vois un truc
segan dénigrer fait 15 non faussée
s'ajouter 500 gagne pas mam est fou
c'est que tu donnes laquelle moi et mes
bons fous ces quatre gagner je suis
chaud aujourd'hui en tactique a gagné la
qualité
by ap a vu six et de kébé 3 qui a aidé
4.2 une menace comme l'a évoqué tu peux
faire bam bam d'air india the damned se
doit la respecter
ouais ouais le pauline dans le très dur
là là il est vraiment dominé r
maintenant j'ai juste moins fort il faut
qu'il donne la callas comment tu le fais
pour eux donc c'est vrai que ce soit il
s'est rendu compte après qu'il avait
raté saab siège qui avait trois tableaux
basse à martigues engament la conne
oui je sais mais j'ai en fait il a dû
comprendre que vous ces quatre aurait
aurait gagné la rédac à la russie après
c'est duda ce genre de position il aime
bien avoir du matériel en moins mais des
pièces qui bouge mais aussi l blues
non c'est sûr mais à régler avec les
noirs tu refuse jamais de jouer ça il ya
cinq ans c'est à dire qu'elle est fou
c'est trois n'échoue première 3.5
c'est quoi la pompe ça marche quand
faire là cinq sont pas simples non c'est
sûr mais ça je me posais la question en
fait il ya vous prendrez théâtre même
moment la tête avec les north à les
tours qui joue c'est complètement dingue
ça le pensent aussi sa tante dams et non
au début je pensais que ces six gagné
ses 5 mai ses 5 c'est hyper fort mais
les tags le foie
papillon prend force et minimes où il va
prendre et va rentrer en inde
sinon tu sais si ce qu'un procès si ces
dessins peintures et dessins qui veut c4
ou des guerres et quatre salles gigote
symove sekkat ou la non il veut garder
son point peut-être bien mais fernand
sauce mais le sait s'inquiéter sur ces
cinq étaient sûrement une faute la
pensée a gagné direct et si photo
reprend des 5 kms
tapons bien ça n'était peut-être pas le
choix à s'inquiéter en crise gros raté
de dresser un sport reading m dames r3
je vois pas en quoi serait pas le roi
noir qui serait plus faible en fait la
sépaq un ou deux et quatre roues des
camions qui sont maintenant bien sûr n'y
a pas tord d un couple de vichy est ce
que c'est et blanc sont une belle pioche
il faut pas envie de te dire maintenant
de revenir on le sait est ici je pense
parce que moi j'ai vite eu fait nul et
s'il bouge la tour au moins je peux
bouger d'autres bateaux et si le jeu le
guingamp - et de juin coupe dame non
mais ya pas de bons coups de projets
pour le garde pour ses habitants
ce crédit est en éruption mais je
pensais que les lotos un le tour en un
schisme il joue le gars qui a fait rage
this way
pour eux quatre sacs jaunes vient
d'amener un c3 mais normalement il ya
assez de jeu dans ce type de trucs des
forains dame accepte ou robbie d'america
d'un petit perpète
ouais ça fait peur genre du coup au des
8,2 me prend 1 à 1 tour 6 4 non tarifs 3
un truc là bas il veut faire une chose
dans mes fans à des médecins yako son
info bref un rush 4 je sens que assez
l'anguille
je vais attentes et même à tanger 5 ça
peut marcher 1 mais après ils donnent
pas un schisme d'orient lâche 3 dames f5
c'est fini dame f5 et tous rêvent 6 à ce
qu'il a fait et pas d'un rêve 5
deux secondes chacun je crois qu'il a
raté le gain mathieu seule la même 5
c'était fini d'aller gagner autant mais
c'est raté par juste regardé par
curiosité de meuf c'est que ça a l'air
de gagner direct non maintenant j'ai pas
vu le gain tous les fous gagner leur vie
d'homme et je me relâche je pense mais
roanne 5e cas d'échec watch quatre coups
c'est quoi la faute c'est inouï insurgés
5e jeu est franc je pense une salle
après ces retours les plus gagnants il a
gagné autant terrible mathieu mais bon
on là je pense qu'il faudrait qu'ils
gagnent une partie parce que là ça fait
une heure et demie qui n'est pas guinéen
il gagnait la dernière il a gagné à 20
minutes
ouais ça fait une heure une bonne heure
une heure dans un match de trois heures
et demie tu gagnes pas c'est long mais
qui la met les barbelés et à didier
barbelés il a mis les barbelés sa magie
semences et didier barbelés mais après
ok ça c'est bien mais c'est bien je me
sens encore sow fait chier ceux ci
carrément il s'est carrément barré soit
en fait ils allaient chercher un une
livraison amazon ont eu berry score ils
veulent manger de la salade les
thématiques à chaque fois qui fait ça
l'option quoi oui c'est ça quand il sait
que jean durand a placé une petite
poisse c'est la brème et duda il a juste
pas niveau honnêtement s'il faut selon
eux au début était complètement de vente
mais là aussi je rends mon fils comme
figé absents qui montrent le niveau
c'est vraiment ça quand celui-là monter
le niveau c'est devenu impressionnant en
fait un hit box de catégorie au dessus
c'est là que tu sens que partout seul
morceau encore et et chantre quoi
arrêter le barça je crois juste que il
est en mode qu'est ce que c'est que ça
je crois qu'il en va de ramener moi
quelqu'un d'un niveau suffisant pour moi
quoi fin mai ya peint c'est que le
matériel
il a déjà une pièce pour des pions non
c'est son style un ouais mais après au
bout d'un moment à ce niveau là mathieu
de la compétition il ya plus de ces son
style tu dois quand même joué
suffisamment correctement qua non et
gercées s'il veut passer le cap
il faudra arrêter ce truc là en fait on
est d'accord ça à un moment donné en
fait ça ça si tu as tu peux monter
top 10 mondial là dessus il ya un moment
donné en fait tu as un gros stock qui
dit en fait les échecs c'est pas ça et
tu peux pas jouer ton style en fait tu
es obligé de jouer la position
correctement parce qu'on est tous des
brutes en fait mais objectivement ce que
ces bêtes son truc
d'autres trois pions en glisse alors non
je pense que je pense je pense que c'est
très bien joué mais je veux dire après
le problème c'est que il joue il joue
trop à l'énergie qua non mais à tête le
team origin
enfin si j'ai l'air tu imagine mal un
truc que tu connais tu es mal à chaque
partie ces deux régions du temps mal
ouais mais avec les plantes et souvent
bien quand même te trompes au-dessus
domine très très souvent donc c'est que
les plantes à parfum d'agrément avec
avec avec les blancs aussi j'ai pu
travailler mais avec les noirs j'ai trop
de mal je peux te la mettre à jour tu as
connu un bref arrêt qu'on voit ce
ensemble mais je sais qu'en ce moment
t'as pas trop trop le temps où il a joué
bien c'est pas 14 tu connais le truc
c'est que je déteste ce type de position
en plus c'est un homme de dos en fait si
je le fais parce que mon objectif serait
de travailler de 4,5
parce que c'est mon type de position
plus mais mais en fait j'en ai marre je
veux cette structure karo kann ça me
saoule
il veut je captais c'est simple c'est
bien joué
peut-être tour de huit échanger et faire
food et un déca parquet prenait 4 pions
prends ta pas trouvé les changer ton
plus de 15 ans mais je ponds point son
job à 21 h je te le dis tout de suite
comme c'est mathieu je suis plutôt pour
pour rester seul dans ce match va alors
on va
ok il faut 4 fossati contrôler ses seins
bates webo majorque de jeu égal mais je
veux que les bulles est super mais je
veux pas forcément qui gagne mais parce
qu'il est plus fort justement parce que
plus fort mais mais la chaldée car il
faudra gagner
on veut kahn qui fait par mois je je
commande face au vent quand je commence
joe biden 60 ans si tu veux faire les
speech and junior mathieu tu es le
bienvenu pas de superbes compétition
mathieu tout de même que tu rates non
génétiques j'en ai regardé un peu à
l'ail belle compétition dans cette île
de france et les premiers taux et à trop
d'écart de niveau à le louer le problème
en fait il faudrait faire un système un
peu comme ils font dans absolument tous
les sports du monde c'est que
c'est que les premiers tours en fait il
dure pas trois fois plus longtemps que
les matchs intéressants en fait à un
moment donné la finale c'était cool les
deux mis aussi mais pas sur les trucs
comme ça tu peux pas avoir des huitièmes
qui dure un mois quoi c'est pas possible
et le spi de chasse pas moi j'aimerais
bien voir d'aider à une année commenté
non jouer où il commentait aussi mais
jouer dédé est là elle a une très
mauvaise passe avec le bébé est là elle
a perdu deux ans si elles étaient 24 70
quinzième mondiale elle était là pas de
70 points ça va revenir ou pas tu penses
bas dans les médias joue pas donc nous
c'est à l'heure quand je suis sorti il
est en train de glisser sur la tablette
c'est bien ça reprend se reprend non
mais ça va revenir à oui mais pas tout
de suite mais l'autre jour t elle était
chez flunch et blatche et murs tapissés
mirta serait sinon quel point ces cinq
groupes
je pense qu'ils calculent sa tête easy
call foulée 5 avant qu'elle et ses cinq
tours des deux tours 2-2 à deux très
bons et je pense que ça sonne le coup
non tactique
quoi il voulait pas carrade mais il veut
avoir du répondant sur cinq
je pense qu'il a du mal à améliorer
encore avec les verts de temps qu
secondes il va tomber de nouveaux
suspects et son maquillage cinq ans et
ça fait mal hein ouais ça se joue à la
connexion mathieu apparemment m réussi
depuis deux trois jours et c'est en fait
il sait pas ce qu'il fait à l'édile
comprends pas dit qui comprend pas ouais
ça je vais peut-être un peu à la
connexion mais ça ça fait plaisir quand
même mathieu sajoo et voilà qu ça fait
moi j'aime bien c'est peut-être de trois
parties en réalité qui paiera la
connexion et du coup si tu peux faire
contre ça rien mais j'adore
je crois que c'est aussi un problème de
court à tout à l'heure après c'est aussi
à lui de passat aussi mal autant si tu
as des petites coupures d'une seconde
faut pas être aussi malin il ya un peu
l'autre chose c'est mérité ouais un
setting est très très très très solide 1
j'ai joué ça il ya 4 5 ans avec les
north et boeing mais bon souvent tu fais
voilà en fait ça fait plus cinq et il
reste deux parties de trois plus un
c'est en réalité la soci fait un sur un
ennemi sur deux il tue le match +6 en
fait c'est vraiment fini
ouais ouais ouais je l'emmène mais c'est
surtout le mec il a pas gagné depuis
deux heures on le redit il ya par une
arène limon un vrai problème
il est il est à peu près au même point
cap dusautoir offre au même moment du
match quoi c'est pas forcément ouais bah
ouais je sais pas quoi dire non mais
t'as pas d'ouverture tapas d'ouverture
j'ai un truc même abdou il était un peu
moins sous pression surtout qu'avec m
j'ai joué ça en islande hier cinq ans
c'est hyper tes oreilles tu peux tu peux
tu peux pas te faire autant dominé que
ça dans les ouvertures c'est trop là on
croirait mois en fait il se fait dominer
plus ou moins au même level que moi dans
les ouvertures
c'est un truc de non ce n'est pas
possible
l'acei vertueux je sais pas ce que je
vois déjà qui s'est déjà trompé dans mes
fans tromper il a fallu la mairie car on
nous dit ce haut domine complètement
ah bah ouais il bat depuis une heure et
c est là il réfléchit il est plus dans
il s'est fait il s'est fait martolet et
la trempe qui changent d'ouverture à
chaque fois assez la classe du top
niveau mais qu'il a changé d'ouverture à
chaque partie et si tu joues quel point
de quintaux décade garder tour c8 et
tousser
mam était au mieux non sinon t'as rien
mais si tu fais pas ça je fais qui avait
17 ans et 8 heures de lutte
kébé 5
qu'est ce que c'est que ça non mais je
pense que je pense qu'il faudrait voir
et qu'on puisse prendre un temps mort en
fait et 17 n'ont apprécié le torse il
faisait 5 par mais se fait déchirer un
et le bouffer à cette rien avions qui
survolent un appartement ça simplement
oui enfin il n'y a pas trop de vols quoi
y'en a un peu non des avions de ligne on
n'a pas beaucoup mais c'est rare en voir
on m'a proposé un tournoi en espagne la
semaine prochaine à soutraire riendeau
vite tu t'en fous tu t'en fous non mais
il a l'air mort de l'intérieur bah ouais
ça se voit il comprend qu'il est moins
fort là il a compris qu'il est
c'est terrible ça psychologiquement
quand tu comprends que tu as tu un mur
en face un fou jce un an
deuxième de ce fait il se fait déchirer
mathieu pendant beaucoup de tours et
femmes
c'est dur de 3 to même très fins et très
fin qui est proche de celle au tour en
f1 mais tu vas prendre une tout rendez
vite même peut-être et tu bouges plus
quoi et ces deux points je fous délicate
qui échappe pas même jaune enfin non
mais après ce qui fait aussi plaisir
c'est que c'est le sait c'est quand même
la rigueur et le travail qu'ils vont
gagner face face au talent brut 1 by
youtube on aime ça me dérange pas de les
gens qui travaillent mais je pense pas
que ce soit moins talentueux que d'où
d'ailleurs jamais oui enfin en fait tu
vois talent équivalent il y en a un qui
a travaillé juste il le défonce quoi
juste il se défonce j'aurais dû pions
avec les dessins peintures
une belle finale mathieu j'aime pas trop
un tour de 8 mais je sais pas si tu veux
aller cherche à monter le round 5 heures
d'efforts non torcé 5 à temps ces cinq
c'est beau
méchant vraiment mais bon il est vrai un
moment donné il a vraiment eu un
problème mais là il chante vraiment moi
j'entends la finale 2 0 des six mois
cette hausse tony a non seulement 1,5
[Musique]
aïe le jeu je vais faire un tour eiffe
tour f à tour f5 fougue et de non droit
des 6 3 5 1 voix décide de fred tempo il
a le temps après il est encore jeune et
1,6 seconde repasser la tour avant 2 kg
car pour provoquer un coup 7 kg
qu'attache trois tours ces cinq cars a
lieu cinq je l'aurais vu comme ça
personne dans ce cinq lits des secteurs
ce deuil à priser quel point 3 donc là
je crois bouge ont besoin cavalli le
cinq cavaliers des trois-tours f5
ouais et détroit je peux pas prendre le
torse et 4gb cinq tours des trois tours
autour d'eux ces quêtes 5,5 il veut tour
c'est un tour de tourner sous le
cadillac et c'est un vrai tour ce doit
être ça n'ya pas parce qu'il ya ça il a
joué avec zéro une des tours c3 et on a
trois tours à dakar et lycéens terminé
bon match ouais trop au dessus
wesley wesley so qui se baladent un sûr
dans ce match aurait des 4 c 5
c'est terrible à duda qui fait n'a pas
soudain ayant fait faut se rappeler
comme il y avait 4 2 duda noda est
gagnant
au bout d'une demi heure demain depuis
les deux nuls 6 défaites 8
faites et défaites c'est là que voilà il
est en quête identitaire
donc il nous reste combien de temps de
se donner en plus cela vraiment
dominateur d'ailleurs soca parent et
l'os si monstrueux que ça dans son site
3128 comme ça ça tacle in web et je dire
c'est le niveau de notre nouvelle donc
j'aimerais bien un match om d'elle même
avait bien sûr chat 24,1 et qui s'est
passé quoi mais c'est comme en match
enfin lors de sauts quand même plus tôt
on est heureux quand le travail qu'ils
gagnent en même temps j'étais pas comme
ça avant mais maintenant je suis un
travailleur to die je suis pas mal dans
les gammes aux orages mais quand tu
perds la confiance aux échanges et 2006
est terrible c'est à la case aux trois
noms on ne peut pas dire que tout âge ou
mal en fait j'ai envie de dire ses sauts
qu'il a éteint en fait un moment donné
en là l'objectif je fous de je pense kg
4 échangé à la fin de votre rien qu'avec
5 et tournai la pollution pendant des
heures le temps peut passer soit retour
à troyes peut-être un jour quelle leçon
ces leçons mathieu il ya vu se révèle ce
pitch et zaoui dernière ouest et russie
sow qui avait gagné mais bon avec ce
confinement mvl qui s'est mis plus au
jeu sur internet même si c'était pas
vraiment sa tasse de thé
il prenait pas ce sont je le vois bien
prendre le truc hyper sérieux à chaque
fois quand même maximy des fois il
jouait un peu plus en des temps de jeu
même s'il a toujours envie de gagner
bien sûr
dans tous les cas il faudra aller le
sortir à wesley dit les dents tout
parent ni quoi il est sur deux finales
d'affilée na waie élaboré la dernière
finale contre na cas ils perdent 3 4
points il est vraiment pas loin on avait
commenté un match de lui les chefs d'
avance nous avait vraiment impressionné
du niveau de jeu aux mines et de joie
il ya aussi il joue vite c'est ça qui
m'avait y perçoit près moi je pense que
sow en 2006 anna k ça peut être un match
énorme
nous dire une collision l'amazoo saaq et
noir ça c'est le pari gagné il n'est pas
loin gagne est prise et que je devais
simplement là toi je pas sûr que leur
équipe b 4 à 5 quelques membres
voici il veut gagner allait droit au
central dames c'est des fois ça marche
ouais saxo 967 impressionnant ce qui
prouve le talent qu'on disait parce que
toute la terre cette fois c'est que tu
peux vous dire je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est vrai il a beaucoup de talent s'il
arrive à être bon sens d'ouverture
ouais mais en 960 saut et il a beau
avoir les ouvertures en classique
bref il est aussi bon aux échecs c'est
comme une position qui est pas trés trés
élèves
bon ça maïs baills bain et en bullet tu
crois qu'il est plus fort hood où
d'aucuns normalement c'est pour ça qu'à
2 3 points d'écart ça aurait pu être
chaud mais je vois pas remonter six
points quoi il peut je dames 1 817 ya
tour celui-ci c'est fou de poggio et
d'ailleurs je crois qu'à un moment donné
quand on peux plus t'en peu plus mature
ici mais moi j'avais connu celui enfin
en plus sort sur damas huit tu vois bien
regarder dame ses sept tours s'est vite
à me prend 17 hors france est un rouage
de tuer quelqu'un j'ai vomi toute
approche lui je sais où tu as quand même
perdre des six way pour savourer les
mets je prends un truc en f5 ce n'est
pas forcément très agréable non plus un
domicile sont autonomes et tu le fais tu
à 33 ans il encore ému demander
n'importe où mais au fait il joue à
contre nature a fait le saut sur
internet
il saute lynda thalie j'étais surtout
under mathieu n'ont jamais en aille
jusqu à 100 avec ma femme me vire je
femme ne le pousse pas une loi
a répondu non j'ai enfin je dis moi
j'avais jamais je pense pas ça me prend
des six
donc il n'y a pas d'âme f6 échec et puis
on prend j'ai six décennies mais de voir
ya peut-être même il a vu les genres
c'est pas volontaire quoi l'art au monde
tu adaptes de temps bull est non mais
non moins sept matches et si son bateau
marchait pas cool de l'influx wife 7
c'est vrai j'ai veillé vous cueille des
5 et 6 7 à 6 les attaques de fou a eu un
contrat de sept ans
qu'est-ce qui manient bien les pièces
way pour les replacer dans les finales
technique car en questionnant fou des
trois ans à faire maintenant
j'étais dit ça pour qu'il la rate salle
à mon avis
voilà comment c'est toujours comme ça
qu'est c1 j'ai fait un tour ces trois
ans autres fous des 3 b et c 3 c'est
très bien besoin
en moi j'ai trois risques risque une
fois 4 ici paris fera quatre essais 3 en
do dièse juin x 4 il te fait h4 il a
fait maintenant on prend ces trois
tombes et 17 temps prend 7 roachs et qua
non il ya airwatch 3,7 g iii prend une
roche
je voulais mater copieusement +7 mathieu
il ya 8 à 1 en 3 + 1 dont les deux nuls
1 2 murray c'est à dire qu'en fait
depuis 4 2 il ya eu deux nuls et dix
victoires
c'est à dire qu'en fait si tu comptes
les nuls dans le truck d'adoption si ces
victoires en fait il vient d'adopter ces
janumet d'isère quoi honnêtement je n'ai
pas vu venir ce début de match ouais
mais là là c'est paraissent pas le même
c'est pas le même les vols mathieu du
coup on a une demi heure le loser en
plus après la demi-heure de vue l'être
quand même pour être bien sûr tous
devenir de bullet et jenson tout change
tout le temps ils nous disent c'est
génial je pense qu'aux veille des
matches alors c'est quoi est-ce que
telle évaluation la hâte une évaluation
n'est pas mise à jour intégré ça marche
bien ce truc non non elle et il m est
alors de temps en temps en fait il as
d'oudaï encore favori ça marche
tellement pas
ce
en tout cas en tout cas belle
démonstration que soit la rigueur un le
match est passé des moments la
démonstration est belle et donc selon
maxime dans le chat tu peux nous dire
quand il joue s'il sait pas mais je
crois qu'il sait pas si génial non c'est
bon terrible on dit y'a quand même un
gros gap entre les joueurs c'est
sidérant bas c'est pour ça qu'en fait
des formats longs comme ça le problème
c'est que ouais fait peut-être sur un
truc en 7 ou quoi il aurait pu se
reprendre et c'est là en fait c'est
juste que tu le cool quoi pour m'envoyer
une vie des autres
c'est un peu dessus je chambrais un peu
les billets maso quand ils ont une
démarche devient très commentée mais là
il ya huit matches sur dix sont pourris
un lanceur ouais je marche je
m'attendais pas à ça je pense
honnêtement je crois je m'étais sous
favori ben moi aussi après apprécié par
contre tu es en train de te dire
justement peut-être que le favori s'est
retourné et en fait pas du tout trop
fort ils ont annoncé le 3 décembre d'un
café d'eau mais c'est une loin le 3 200
ça fait plaisir on voit un peu souffler
beaucoup de matches là mathieu 3
décembre 2021 pourquoi pas ça fait
plaisir je peux te dire ne pas avoir de
date ce week end il ya des gens qui sont
contents ans mathieu une tout aussi une
non pas forcément parce que je t'aide
stream d'autres choses du coup mais tu
vois c'est à cause du truc tueuse 24
ouais non ça ce programme c'est quoi les
dots alors de son ca commence dimanche
normalement on commente le dimanche avec
baky d'ailleurs le truc 7,24 d'accord
c'est quoi les dates jeu contre le st
monsieur p soir le problème fin qui nous
dit qu'on a un peu sévère avec duda le
problème c'est qu'il a le même problème
en partie longue depuis déjà deux ans et
en fait si règle ils règlent pas le
problème ni en partie longny en rapide
et donc c'est moi j'ai un petit nom
c'était l'occasion de le faire quoi moi
c'est un pote à moi et je lui ai dit
qu'il fallait qu'ils fassent mal ben moi
j'aime bien mon sang mon entraîneur mais
c'est trop léger après est-ce qu'il a
pas beau c'est vachement de l'ouverture
des soldes sur internet
maintenant va irriter en norvège il
était un peu à l'ouest aussi à seysses à
caen sur la truck achats à magna partie
déjà au le chai la sicile achats au nom
il est trop mignon au nom mathieu pas
désolé c'est le moment chat désolé je te
coupe on le voit pas bien employé sur le
site depuis 22 ou 30 loto maïs est
vraiment très bientôt
et du coup tu vas te monte tous les
jours ceux non non pas du tout non c'est
juste avec baky le premier jour mais
s'il ya des trucs mais non le format est
pas très peut être encore moins
intéressant que le speech à sion il faut
une compétition en fait en fait à 12
joueurs au début il ya huit qualifiés
enfin bon c'est sérieux c'est du 15 +10
ces premiers jours en suède délire est
pas qui mais je ne j'ai peur que ce soit
après on sait pas tant que t'as pas vu
tu sais pas exactement mais ça me faire
de ce gibier au téléphone parce qu'il va
travailler un peu pour ce truc là il m'a
expliqué non au moins l'avantagé c'est
que au niveau de l'open il y aura des
partis qu'on voit pas trop ouais mais
mais mais trois jours de qualification
on 15 + 10 les cinq heures par jour
pendant trois jours pour pour éliminer
quatre joueurs c'est trop ou alors il
faudrait qu'il en garde que 2 à la fin
oui mais en fait tu peux pas face et
élimine 25% des joueurs tu passes déjà
trois jours sur le truc c'est ça affreux
mais le ch est trop mignon mathieu oui
ou non mais tu es d'accord c'est trop
ouais ça semble trop lourde avance mais
le truc c'est que normalement avant il
aurait fait huit jours pour les éliminer
les joueurs donc là ils ont progressé
ouais mais bon 3 c'est quand même trop
ou alors il faudrait faire des groupes
tu vois feinte à 12 joueurs attaquent à
4 4
trois groupes de quatre ah j'en sais
rien moi tu qualifies je fais qu'annick
de carli prend des joueurs en plus tu
qualifies les deux premiers de chaque
groupe et tu sais tu que les phases
finales c'est très intéressant après ça
avec les mêmes joueurs à chaque fois un
ouais la cadence pour internet c'est
trop long aussi internet c'est du blitz
est à pourvoir
donc je le sens pas trop mais après je
peux me tromper
c'est un avis de première vue ça va être
trop lourd mais après on va voir du
positif on va essayer deux premiers
jours avec baky on verra ouais
après peut-être les phases demi finale
oui ou non ça peut-être mais aussi apte
à dix tournois pareil dans la nécessaire
que le premier toit c'est peut-être cool
mais après le troisième le quatrième et
le cinquième
c'est ce qu'on s'est dit avec masoni vie
on se dit au bout du troisième je pense
au moins trois touchés ouais ouais je
pense aussi puisqu'on va être à chaque
fois leurs trois jours de qualification
enfin c'est le seul choix qui va le
faire venir d'autres joueurs sont pas
toujours les mêmes mais sachant que tu
prends les huit premiers de chaque
tournoi qui reviennent bon on verra on
va attendre que faut attendre un peu
avant de critiquer même si on sait qu'on
l'a critiqué non mais moi je on va dire
que j'ai un mauvais pressentiment mais
j'espère que ce soit bien moi ça
m'arrange qui sait bien à la rigueur rob
et moi si c'est génial et tout c'est
super pour moi donc je suis plutôt pour
j'espère que ce soit bien mais je le
sens pas trop manger une question est ce
que mon ami ou était mieux que la fois
ouais mais attend ce chat un sacré de
birmanie et tout est super mignon son
chat ou wesley à jet airways la région
est pour et sa fonte d'art il en photo
de profil le chat est partout quoi ils
pouvaient pas lutter douteux
c'est un chat pareil c'est terrible les
maximes il joue alors ou pas là le
prochain
ah oui il est d'un réalisme alors il ya
qui comme nouveau joueur il ya anton
radjabov li kwong need it 2 2 osk bon
sinon tu as pas très fort en vrai y en a
qu'un pas encore t il il montre un gars
par jour là c'est bizarre ça faisait
trois jours avant tu as toujours pas la
liste des joueurs scan spéciale aïe
libye la nuit là parrot dire bah mon
avis les deux derniers sénat quelques a
annonc arsène déjà été annoncés grégoire
maca pour le premier quand même d'être
les bonnes
je n'ai pas d'ennemis en pointe je te
donne la liste ding leeuwen radjabov
anton kayak in nyc room wesley so guigou
d'oeuvres dites carcelle vachier lagrave
iannone premiership
zidane lui manque deux matches et pas
j'aime pas trop le line-up enfin on lui
dit il s'est fait dominer comme mazodier
deux jours - les green day fait pas tout
de suite
bon alors c'est parti pour le bullet
mathieu avec sept points d'écart alors
je t'annonce que normalement c'est neuf
bullet max a donc c'est possible c'est
possible est ce que est ce qu'il y aura
des arbitres à domicile pour vérifier la
triche ou est ce que ce sera à la fête
du slip comme d'hab le toit de quoi là
pour le tournoi de magnus ici sans
fondement à maxime morin
[Musique]
enfin disons qu'en blitz déjà quand
c'est la fête du slip avec les calmes
c'est chaud mais en 15 + 10 c'est c'est
eric c'est la fête du slip
1 je crois qu'ils avaient prévu de
durcir un peu j'avais lu mais on va pas
intéresser puisque son nom balladur
certes façon sans arbitre à domicile tu
dis rien du tout hein on verra on verra
mais déjà là après moi je suis pas du
genre qui inquiète ses trois mois toi
t'es pas trop parano
en fait je vois pas l'intérêt de lettres
as que si demain j'organise on va dire
le tour de france et que j ok les gars
c'est la fête du slip je vérifie pas le
dopage ne vérifient pas les vélos pour
voir s'il ya des moteurs dedans tu
regardes ou non mais si oui parce que
honnêtement je préférais le cyclisme
quand il y avait de tout reprendre cette
saga n'y est pas tout de suite qu'il
préfère les échecs quand ça triche n'ont
pas intérêt d'y penser
parce que dans tous les cas ça va
déprimer de savoir aimer ça veut dire
que demain je les entends le 3 je le
gagne sans problème
y'a pas de vérification sarr aucun
intérêt ccja c'est comme si tu vis dans
un monde une anarchie sans police sans
rien tu sors dehors les gens qui tirent
à la kalach tu diffères un toit au bout
d'un moment quand on plaint porte mes
rapports mais dans ce que je veux juste
dire c'est que là dans les tons - élite
moi j'espère juste qu'ils trichent pas
s'ils trichent basse et les cons mais ça
mais je sais bien faire un moment donné
il faut quand même une vérification pour
pour pouvoir regarder en toute sérénité
et mieux car il était complètement
gagnant on est maintenant qu'est mieux
mais c'est aussi un roi c'est trois noms
peut-être la gagner
hitchcock ça laisse par six jours plus
tard 6 j'en attends c'est cette qu'un
moins que ça ouais mais bon tu envoies
passe devant il ya à vis de qui tombent
chez pas c'est hyper flou c'est bien
joué ça à 4,1 me sun bolt a laissé
repartir une espérance épingle
christophe lemaitre non mais ça devrait
aller
parce qu'en fait le même coup ses pions
bob fosse et 7 2 6 2 en fait ce sens
avec un se serait tu te ferais sacrifier
sa feraient plus peur des six allers sa
part de la pelouse 6 alors attend
souvent plus si les dégâts c'est à dire
que lui quand il est mieux dans le match
il tâche jusqu'au matin alors harry a
été que la fin il va pas abandonner ça
c'est sûr il va essayer de la tenir le
plus longtemps possible pour faire
tourner la montre achetée annonce que ça
va être dégueulasse surpris non mais
j'ai déjà vu j'ai déjà vu l'homme à
l'oeuvre donc je t'annonce qu'il va
jamais abandonner en fait là il va y
avoir maintenant prochain il va arrêter
jouer oui je laisse tomber à une
terrible
ah oui il y en a rien à faire là où moi
je déteste tout ça bah oui mais alors là
monsieur cornette tu vas voir ça pendant
des heures ah oui ça fait plaisir
vous ne dit que le maître est plus
rapide que bolt en vitesse de pointe
d'accord c'est possible je serai pas ces
choses je m'appuyais le vérifier oui
c'est un compétiteur ouais mais c'est
bien mais il a raison de faire ça pour
moi il mène au score si tu veux ça doit
lui donner un privilège quand même ça va
lui donner un avantage non mais tu fais
pas plus cette fois-ci l'autre revient
le c'était calme match j'ai regardé un
match où il y en a il a failli s'est
faite au cf
il a failli perdre parce qu'il n'a pas
fait ça il se fait égaliser parce qu'il
n'a pas fait ça ouais
déjà 1 à la patte de feydeau moi je le
suis avec toi je compte tu te bouges de
le faire ce que tu sais club peut
revenir et restent pas longtemps mais là
il ya plus cette
tu fais ça les deux dernières parties
non black tapie dit bah c'était pas toi
qui disais que ça faisait partie du jeu
c'est exactement ce que je suis en train
de lire black tf ça fait partie du jeu
c'est dégueulasse mais j'adore moi je
ferais pareil comme et de d'être démonté
nice et des français ah oui il te fait
un autre truc extraordinaire c'est que
si tu abandonnes pas quand il est devant
il cherchait les coûts pour être le plus
haut de 37 ans a gagné pour ce faire
tourner la montre à ils étaient rivés
exceptionnel mais je le dis je le voyais
plus dans nos mentalités dans le maine
un saut je voyais pas comme ça je pense
qu'en fait mais aussi c'était ce que le
formal soul et qui va en tirer parti du
coup tu vois ces cinq bien joué quand tu
es mal pour le prouver cette eau - vie
la pure 1 4 qui traînent brayelle 3 15 k
un peul prendre nos efforts en g3 la fin
pour simple nom mais la pendule aussi
c'est dans les sauts très très
simplement votre beaucoup trop fort
beaucoup trop fort et il va te faire
parrainer toutes les parties cette
exception et j'ai hâte de revoir une
partie oui les gagnants je suis très
choix ça fait tellement plaisir pas pour
le cut à la famille harris qui trinquent
gains c'est plus clair soit 6 il a tort
qui traîne
hannachi ce qu'il est il est fiable à
oka pas vu un niveau de jeu exceptionnel
ce soir mesdames et messieurs de vienne
me voir nos cracheurs de vie
exceptionnelle d'arâches 6 ya du
l'evalia du level ce soir mes amis
honnêtement ce moment j'ai ressenti ce
comme gérer pas de 100 points je le fais
mais en plus en trois minutes donnent la
dame mais il va quand même la gagne et
saluera ça leur a permis de faire couler
plus de temps c'était stratégique les
amis très bien joué elle a hélas c'est
génial parce que je pense que vu qu'il
fait le truc des gueux je pense que le
match est déjà terminée en fait c'est
sur 25 minutes complètement finie
d'abord on va revoir le truc des gamins
je vends mon espoir c'est que 12 à aider
position gagnant c'est que les femmes
vivent plus longtemps possible
exceptionnel ça tient à qui calculent
qu'ils regardent la vitesse de pointe du
sénat ils ont dit qu'ils étaient plus
rapides d'entre eux sont alors bon comme
le défaut ans quand ce qu'on n'y a pas
d'enjeu tu dis pour monde c'est terrible
car il est encore moins bien que les
blancs car de vous et du campus kg ha
c'est que l'enjeu et des 10 juillet donc
au début en fait y'a pas trop d'enjeu ce
que ça commence donc tu vas pas trop
s'exciter puisque c'est le début et en
fait à la fin les matches seront
terminés donc c'est génial tata par
l'enjeu si ça que j'adore
pourquoi mail de l'enjeu free style
vraiment des gens pour croire que je
mettrais qualité supérieure ce serait
théoriquement possible une vitesse de
pointe supérieure en fait c'est
impossible mais moi ça me fait très
plaisir à ces moments préférés dans les
matches serrés mais bon j'espère que ça
joue ça il faut que ça joue très
longtemps des finales complètement
inintéressante là je suis dans mon
élément la tour des 3 boom the old boys
un tour des trottoirs c'est un x 3 tous
deux on tient toujours
elle tient la baraque toujours vivant en
fait moi je suis quelqu'un qui adore
l'absurde
j'aime beaucoup l'absurde en général que
ce soit dans la peinture dans le j'aime
bien les livres absurde et georgia de
tchadors boris vian par exemple dans les
scènes absurdes et du coup en fête ou
python ouais les monty python j'adore et
du coup on fait danser speech s comme le
truc est absurde le format pour moi est
absurde
j'aime quand on touche le sommet de
l'absurdité du truc ça me fait vraiment
réellement qui fait je trouve qu'il ya
une beauté à sa finalement tu vois je
parce que le format devient sens le seul
sens qu'il a c'est son ridicule en fête
est donc quelque part en fait pour moi
il fait tout son sens là maintenant en
fait c'est la beauté du truc que moi je
veux une réelle beauté maintenant dans
ce truc là était fan de boris vian jeu
je chante le déserteur 1 filles elles
n'en ont pas moins des bouquins ouais
moi je connais quelques poèmes mais en
chansons mais du coup pour moi je
retrouve un peu ça dansait ce pitch
assez serré pour moi c'est le speech à
ce fait tous toute sa beauté et le
format fait tout son saoul live arrive à
répéter un peu non on sait qu'il est
réputé pour gain de temps non
mais j'adore aussi calmes et bien
évidemment l'étranger extraordinaire bah
ça peut être beau la partie peut durer
très longtemps nous parle andrew steve
irak
je connais pas un taux rejettons
peut-être que dd connaît d'ailleurs même
si elle n'est pas layton lituanie
lettonie est pas loin
cette nature si je vous ai fait
découvrir romain gary emile ajar et
parce qu'être humain c'est qu'il est né
un minus sa foi des gens ne savent pas
et c'est mince et quittera ils ont
traduit ces livres c'est que récemment
en lituanien il n'a pas vécu très
longtemps à paris il a voyagé pour
jusqu'à maintenant passée avec sa mère
en france avec sa mère
la promesse de l'homme je conseille mais
j'aime beaucoup ce dlc seydoux n'a en
fait il faut jusqu'au bout c'est sûr que
j'aurais bon allez claes a fait + 8 il y
avait encore un semblant une chance sur
mille
sur un million pardon et la maintenance
assez là c'est vraiment terminé
facile toujours d'ascétisme dixsaut
dominant fond ce match et qu'il ya qui
est estoniens donc ouais désolé c'est le
ban
c'est votre chance goldman sachs en
somme il devrait lâcher la ferme ils
n'ont pas le droit d'abandonner le match
ça qui est tellement extra c'est aussi
ça qui est extraordinaire c'est que t'as
pas loin d'abandonner
c'est génial tel fichier de jeu jusqu'au
bout 1 c'est l'explication c'est pour
savoir à qui dois tu peux aller manger
après ça c'est pour être bien sûr ceux à
éviter
en théorie non duda et sans savoir
vraiment mis un peu de vitesse mais très
honnêtement
on l'a vécu avec m ce qu'on fait du
sport au niveau aussi j'imagine quand tu
fais une compétition en un contre un et
tu perds l'ascendant psychologique
c'était même si tu es plus fort ouais
c'est vrai c'est un sentiment tu te sens
tu sais plus jeune tu veux plus moi même
c'est difficile de se remettre vraiment
réussir à souffler en gagner une et à
construire dessus gagne pas d'ailleurs
c'est de là que vient le fameux conseil
de mur face gagné une partie en réalité
ouais pour repartir à partir en gagner
une autre
les cerfs-volants de romain gary ouais
mais même la vie devant soi beaucoup et
même oui c'est celle là il faut vraiment
gagner une partie la ccabp le conseil
est réel rien alors je les dix ans
moment pour déconner et qui l'a pas fait
inoubliable à wil a gagné une en règle
il est le premier du latin sinon elle
n'a pas gagné de toute la session des
trois ouvriers en plus ça va aller en
plus à l'éperlan tu l'as en plus
j'arrive à on a gagné une en bulles est
entraînée par hasard c'est un peu
méchant de dire par hasard mais est en
fait même ambühl est là il se fait
dominer de chez dominé en fait c'est
quoi tu joues un oui il a eu deux bons
coups mais après c'est interdit du coup
en fait si il a menti sur son identité
il a écrit sous le pseudonyme de hajar
la vie devant soi ça y est c'est pour ça
qu'il a gagné parce qu'en battant tout
le monde disait qu'il était has been qui
était fini du coup il a dit je vais bien
vous [ __ ] je vais me rentrer un autre
nom et d'après bon c'est un grand
dépressif dans l'avenir je pense mais je
pense qu'on puisse ou non n'a rien à
[ __ ]
il veut juste la jaune avec pearl
options et les qualifie ça en fait
j'étais dit en fait quand il a gagné le
match ça le sou la faune et des cats et
les hommes s'ils foutent pas le québec à
deux fois
trois fois non mais là ça guy nato a
zappé rejet de jeudi mais il faut il en
a plus rien à faire mais quand c'est
comme ça c'est déjà parlé contre abdou
sow turf
toni bou d'oudaï la super content à la
caméra mais en fait cela ne veut rien à
[ __ ] en fait il veut juste que le
match se termine plus rien à faire en
fait ça c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
aussi dans ce format territoire
eux-mêmes en fait en plus rien à faire
c'est c'est pourquoi c'était dur c'est
au volant le 6 h 2 trop long là ils
veulent à tenir le plus longtemps
possible trésor américain il peut primer
bonnes mains l ex qu'est ce qu'on me
[Musique]
laisse tomber bon là qu'est affaire aux
h2k m à 0 2 pour pour gagner une petite
demie seconde soit réservé le resto à
21,30 ses impressions objectif c'est de
ces jeux le minimum de participation
fait je comprends en fait ça le soul de
jouer il essaye juste de faire des
parties de faire durer le plus longtemps
possible et ayant joué le minimum en
fait est ce que tu pense qu'on va avoir
un autre match avant le loto - qui
commence où tu penses pas on va de ce
pas
c'est tellement marrant
qu'est ce qu'il veut faire prise à 13h04
ça bouge et 4
[Musique]
ok ça comme ça c'est une heure et quart
quel match et et puis les caisses
j'adore x3 est encore là c'est plutôt on
est plutôt dans leur haine jeu
honnêtement on est plutôt au dessus de
la moyenne dans le règne non match ils
m'arrêtent d'enfance c'est l'esprit des
jeunes à quito c'est à déprimer de ceux
normalement non comme ça j'aurai dû
moyenne à prendre le fond des 6 et
dernier tome où le sou fou prend
efficace d'un musée trois membres au
regard regarde les matchs du premier
tour
du calme at vraiment serré scène par am
non nous n'a qu'à non martirossian non
ok massimi il était devant et pas non
plus ouais mais bon on va dire mac
signalé abdou sunea soit vous soit enfin
dire non et non j'attends à 4 sur 8
maxime un peu plus mais oui dans l'es4
ce rythme là ça fait ça fait ça fait 4
sur 8 on va dire que les quatre 4 autres
étaient bien tu as fait d'os je rougis a
fait deuxième seulement en objet génial
on est d'accord les vonn n'est pour
c'était sympa ils se trompent pas
d'accord
[Musique]
sauf qu'à roanne à moi ça va non caruana
au canada où il ya trois matchs
intéressants photo c'est ça sur mesure
sur le t4 en prenant maxime bon on a
envie de faire le fort se remettent en
fait pas trois matches tu as trois
matchs sur sur sur neuf qui sont
intéressants et ses genres le moment où
tout doit être intéressant parce que
j'ai l'air c'est en fait tu enlèves les
quatorze matches sur 16 de speech junior
qui était mauvais les 24 matches sur 26
de speechless féminin qui était mauvais
vin croire à un moment donné le ratio
c'est juste pas possible quoi après
quand les matches sont bien ils sont
vraiment bien mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'un fedoseyev firoud déjà tu le
mets dans un autre format ça va être
bien aussi en fait il sera toujours bien
peu importe mais naked abandonné le jour
comme la part des pommes aux côtes qui
s'y fait de donner trois dont un
exceptionnel non mais inquiète
exceptionnelle chez dow cfd ja c'est
vrai qu'il était exceptionnel
après il ya eu deux très bons de bons
matches deux ou trois bons mois tu vois
non mais oui c'est perfectible
non mais disons qu'en fait les ouais
c'est juste que tu arrêtes ce match là
il ya une heure une heure et demie du
match et qui classe une autre impression
en fait imaginer avant gorki qu'un seul
cours et conduit tout retaper les gars
tous les images d'accéder à ce que je
pense qu'ils auraient plus de tennis en
fête
l'indicé qui ferme le soir je suis allé
à melbourne
ces cd tu as des passes pour une soirée
toi et il y avait djoko et je voulais le
voir je veux voir fédérer djoko et
j'étais allé jeter au deuxième rang je
t'ai hyper bien passé votre premier tour
n'était pas très fier mais avant il ya
eu des purges dans les limbes
dans les autres sports en fait
l'avantagent c'est quand ils font des
purges que là on est déjà au niveau il
ya plus de purges normalement fait quand
il ya des purges le truc c'est comme le
système de 7 et de points va quand même
assez vite s'insurge sont pas aussi
longue là c'est pas le problème qui est
des purges ça c'est normal et c'est dans
tous les sports le problème c'est que
les purges dure quatre heures en fait
c'est ça le problème en fait l'un
mettons le système de 7 ce monsieur
cissé série à 3 707 le nom s'il ya deux
semaines et on dit d'accord ou non mais
je sais mais c'est juste parce que tu
dis c'est que ça ex dans les eaux sport
oui oui c'est sûr c'est juste un réseau
sport ait eu le sens pas à jouer au
tennis le 4e et le 5e set quand il ya
des a350 qua non montada commence là
c'est pas une question de ce que de
continuer à se battre ou quoi c'est que
c'est juste mathématiquement fini depuis
un petit moment quoi ouais c'est ça les
purges sont aussi longues que les matchs
serrés c'est bizarre en fait c'est comme
si la finale djoko nadal de
l'australienne qui avait été
extraordinaire dure tant de temps que le
premier tour complètement landes à paris
c'est complètement illogique
ou alors tout le temps dans cinq sets tu
passes la finale en un set ça serait
aussi bizarre l'anti jeu est fini ouais
mais là c'est le règlement
bah ouais cette annonce va perdre toutes
les parties en fait il y en a plus rien
à faire il a déjà fait ce qui fait ça à
chaque fois on fait une fois que le
match est vraiment mathématiquement
gagner c'est dire que le personnes
passaient ouais c'est ça la différence
c'est que le tennis s'est pas fait c'est
jamais fini jusqu'au dernier point en
fait le sival même là en fait ce serait
nous quand on a fait nos compétitions
système de cette je rappelle d'un match
il ya quelqu'un qui est mené 3 0 1 0
donc hyper de quatre points dans ne te
tourner
bliss l'hymne cup il ya 1 1
et du coup la partie du deuxième set il
est gagnant il rate le 2 1 ça fait 2 1
pour l'autre il revient au score 2-2 il
perd le set 3 2 mai et du coup il perd 2
sets 0 mais en fait un match qui dans ce
format là aurait été complètement finie
et auraient regardé par dessus la jambe
tout d'un coup c'est redevenu serré et
puis après quoi il a perdu une partie
c'était fini mais du coup en fait tu as
eu la pression de te dire est ce qu'il
gagne le deuxième ça tire bien contre le
cours du jeu après on sait pas ce qui va
se passer quoi bon moi j'ai toujours des
regrets à l'aller contre robert way back
j'ai tellement bien joué au deuxième set
sont écroulés comme ça une déposition
guénard mais il sait il est passé à un
autre hic est contre moi s'est pas bâti
notre 14
donc du coup ça montre bien que le match
n'était pas selon alors ici pour que la
montana est vraiment lieu mais oui de
toute façon les formats de cette ça
existe dans tous même les fléchettes
faut un format de cette maman qui ne
pondent tout absolument tout fait un
format comme ça en fait tous les bovins
vivants informé comme ça comment pour
les flécher trouve ça rend hyper bien
ouais non plus cela permet de souffler
un peu ce qu'au niveau pression quand
même hein les premières un future lâche
un peu tu dis ok ce paraphe je me
concentre déjà sur la prochaine quand tu
sais que tu vas perdre on est là il est
anti ce brouillard six minutes
choi perte ou non en fait il était
tellement de vent qui s'est complètement
déconcentrer mais je crois que dans sa
tête il switch vraiment en mode je crois
que c'est rendu troll ce que le joël à
une finale gagnée contre abdou s'auto
rohff et il a tout fait pour mettre le
plus de temps pour la gagne est possible
et je fus il a fini par faire venu il
l'a fait du récent 25 ou quoi et c'est
vrai qu'il ya des très heureux de sa
connerie en avant si je suis les
fléchettes
j'ai une petite période où je suivais
pas mal regardé beaucoup de vidéos
j'aime beaucoup anne mazeau on adore et
notre rêve c'est allé voir une
compétition de fléchettes il ya une
ambiance de dingue d'aller en irlande
ce faire un match mais bon le point fort
des fléchettes et toujours pareil c'est
qu'ils ont tellement un bon format que
le match est excitant faut faire nous
finir le truc avec la fléchette tu peux
tu peux complètement mené un set pas
réussir à fermer une manche d'où tu es
dans ta tête et de faire remonter
non mais en a mais regardez les
meilleures vidéos là le néerlandais
l'allemand a demandé avec les suivants
vangard ben non je ne commence pas son
nom pour ce que j'ai dit il c'est que
taylor avant qu'ils étaient très forts
ouais ouais bah il avait l'autre là le
néerlandais il dit de lui que l'autre
est le meilleur joueur de tous les temps
même si lui il bat qui lui prend tous
ses records un par un
mais non c'est un beau jeu a pas
longtemps qui a passé quelques tours au
championnat du monde de snooker ma de
fléchettes nos coeurs je veux j'en ai
fait l adore aussi sean o'sullivan ya un
reportage sur lui sur youtube qui est
génial c'est aussi un format de manche
ouais c'est pas un format de temps c'est
un faux radar ans un peu loin l'idée
quand ils jouent les finales sur
d'autres jours non mais c'est un super
beau jeu plus que cinq minutes
plus que cinq minutes deux matches ça
ces fichiers qu'une trentaine de pick
roues à temps d'étendre aux dames la
pétanque aussi assez mon plus grand
regret cette année c'est que j'ai pas pu
jouer à saint-affrique
parce que tous les ans pour un taux
d'échec est un terrain de pétanque et je
suis tenant du titre des taux de
pétanque de saint-affrique et les
d'avant j'avais perdu en finale je suis
sur deux finales défier j'étais guzzo
alors attend peu de temps que en
répétant que c'est quoi ces premiers à
15,13 premier à 13
après souvent ils font un système de
poules et après six éliminations de
nouveau tome était bon à la pétanque ou
non j'en ai fait quand j'étais gamin
fait mais après j'ai la page pendant dix
ans ça j'suis pas bon goût mais bon
mieux que la moyenne des gens ben t'es
pas un grand joueur de pétanque
non là où je n'étais pas mauvais jeune
c'était la peau bien je t'ai pas si
mauvais mais bon après c'est pas non
plus c'est pas non plus un gros gros
niveau météo poule tav autre que pierre
dans tous les bars ça m'arrive commencé
la partie de finale à table oui c'est
pas mal j'ai dû faire ça dit fois dans
ma vie non c'est pas non plus mais oui
non mais j'y ai passé beaucoup de temps
au lycée je faisais plus sales des
échecs largement tu faisais plus de deux
ans j'ai fait une année de baby foot
parce que j'avais un baby-foot de bach à
la maison d'ailleurs je vais toujours
mais bon il est il est dans la cave
j'ai déjà un monnayeur à deux francs
j'ai gardé les pièces de deux fronts
pour pouvoir l'utiliser et après j'ai
arrêté j'ai fait via un terrible mois au
lycée j'ai pas fait beaucoup d'échecs
c'était comme une petite colonne passif
et des chiens encore ce qu'il était bien
et qu'on était de +2 attendant qu'elle
est noire
du coup c'est clair en fait
du coup c'est moins clair mariette enfin
youtube 1 tu veux te faire échanger et
ou renforcent échec échec échec et un ça
marchait pas et vous réussissent
comment se faire un sport sérieux pour
hachette c'est pas le gros coup de merde
oui on me demande si je serai revenu à
kilkenny cette année bah ouais quand
j'ai vu masotta lors on aurait dû
attaquer finir c'est une prochaine c'est
bon alors le temps des cinq saga ça va
faire nul non j'avais un petit objet pas
un bon dîner oui mais vous êtes pourquoi
pas garder des pieds de de france je
trouve ça marrant
une petite nuit dernière auparavant la
dernière c'est la dernière mathieu 52
zone à l'est on la commente un système
de londres j'ai réussi encore être
chauffée bref c'est pas compte en suisse
à mathay pas il y avait la case affûtent
sais pas comment tu fais mathieu je fais
pas des choses
fuji 4 c'est bizarre mais bon je suis
pris a pas si longtemps à 3 et 4 220
qu'est ce qu'on fait je prends c5125 bon
ces cinq jours a jamais fait le sens
qu'il faut prendre ce sens et quelques
foulées saint cloud price is your âgées
prend et socke a décidé de se
déconnecter a été co sarl et d'écossé tu
as et comme tout à l'heure il a fait un
peu la même truc la même tête tout à
l'heure quand il était dès qu il a
clairement un problème de connexion
maintenant c'est une tête 40e seconde
mais tout ça est déconnecté ouais ça va
se finir ça va se finir sur un beau
moment de sport sous qui se barre il n'a
plus rien à faire du bislett c'est
extraordinaire et duda qui va perdre et
moi aussi je suis déconnecté tout le
monde est déconnecté mathieu quel parti
tu as eu le nez creux un extraordinaire
extraordinaire ça se finit sur un énorme
moment de
de sport après la prochaine fois tu
m'aurais invite quand tu remets ça gt gt
gâtés ah ouais non la tâte to tatou
talent et des connexions de par tout
assaut qui s'est barré qui n'a plus rien
à faire
belle belle fin de match
ils sont vraiment way dans le site
marche vraiment plus près ces extras
bien cette chasse comme petits bugs et
jenny question de ce que doivent faire
écla nation ah ouais je pense alors
malheureux non l extraordinaire cette
dernière partie voilà c'est tout ce
qu'on aime et d'ailleurs du dock et
gagner les une minute mais en galérant
sur la chaîne sheth yanez qui a dit que
le match était passionnera et mais ils
sont même passionné par par lena ka
martirossian et où coexistent était très
beau match à chaque fois donc mais j'ai
regardé un peu pour ce bon je te regarde
souvent mais je regarde un peu désordre
ils sont beaucoup on ressent beaucoup
plus sérieux ils sont très sérieux
télébec ça bouge parce analyse la
position pendant quatre heures n'ya pas
mais ça plaît quinze mille personnes car
yard
là il ya quelque chose une personne qui
regarde la déconnexion de ce bouquet
atakan déjà six sept mille personnes
deux premières pages plus 4300 et qui
sont à 3,4 me l'organique 1 c'est c'est
eh bien c'est à dire qu'on sait lengagne
que ça veut dire que c'est ouais en gros
ils ont deux fois plus de gens qui nous
ment en organique
si tu enlèves les premières pages et
c'est que deux fois plus ouais parce que
premières pages ils prennent de 10000 au
petit imagine que premières pages
d'affaires on prend quatre mille donc
première page en anglais tu prends entre
huit et dix mille ta première page sur
thiès comme ta machin way dont peut-être
ils ont peut-être organiquement trois à
quatre mille personnes peut-être 5000
mais un nom n'y a pas assez pas ça
dépend des matches après ok bon du coup
on attend au dessus ou non là
franchement je pense assez important
d'être bien sûr mathieu dans des dans
des conditions pareilles
mais oui c'est vraiment barré année soit
il met sa veste et où il se barre de
chez lui en fait on voit qu'il ya un
truc à faire ils comprennent i sort de
chez lui il s'est habillé pour se barrer
en fait mais en pire il perd
s'en fout ouais c'est ça y'a plus rien à
[ __ ] c'est génial c'est extraordinaire
oui les noailles chose comme une marche
pas chez moi
ouais c'est extraordinaire et moi non
plus ouais c'est extraordinaire ah si
certains noms ça marche pas ça fait
plaisir ou là ou [ __ ] c'est quoi ce
truc quoi goethem il est avec amr dans
un live chose comme ça
amr hilmi soit jusqu'au partout alors il
a pas 2 juin footon au foot avec lui
fait des fautes et après il se plaint
gueule surtout ses coéquipiers la
mentalité
moi j'ai pas trop aimé parce qu'ils sont
bagués exprès en aréna pour les mecs
moins fort je n'aime pas trop non mais
j'ai joué contre une aussi nombre est
pas mais c'est pas le genre de gens qui
me que j'avais personnellement mais
après quand on est quand il était jeune
a assez connu j'avais j'avais contre lui
n'avait fait nulle en analyse et je
l'avais trouvée n'enlevons pas actif est
la personne tant prédite aux pinceaux
sont en fait ça se voit qu'il doit
partir de chez lui tant il s'habille et
où il en mode je pars et où il est
revenu à l'écran site web est clairement
clairement oui j'adore
j'adore mais c'est dommage ce n'est pas
une partie décisive pour la dernière du
coup je suis un peu déçu quand même en
quelque sorte je suis quand même déçu
royal shia le shaq est de retour au il a
mis le chagrin son panier nous on ne
voit pas c'est sur le deuxième caméra
ouais en fait là le chat sur le panier
là il a le panier du chat sur lui avec
le chat dedans ah non moi je veux qu'on
voit le chat moi je vois le chat sur
l'autre calmes c'est terrible
raju mais l'autre calmes mais non je
sais pas si je peux cela donne aux
jeunes non mais là ils sont en train de
façon là ils sont lents mais il quitte
le match là 10 le match est terminé tout
pour moi le match et matériel ad un
parti n'a pas été jouer je vois pas
pourquoi on met pas cette partie en jeu
sa part et c'est quand même ouais bon
bain mathieu s'est finie sur sur cette
partie fillon décevant temps puisqu'on
sera pas bien sûr ouais on sera pas bien
sûr mathieu 1,8 belle fin de match je
pense je suis je suis désolé mathieu de
t'avoir fait vis ce match de quatre
heures sans savoir lequel des deux était
le plus fort et on se retrouve à
vraiment en fait je vais faire un raid
sur ma chaîne du coup ça marche de bonne
soirée et à bientôt j'espère je professe
des trucs ah bah oui quand tu veux mais
après c'est pas toujours tu es malade de
ça j'ai pu le commis de la petite adore
le sport c'est important seul ouais nan
franchement ça va beaucoup mieux après
donc à la mi mai dehors le soir c'est
pas pareil dès mi course avant de
démonter pourrait jouer de telle info
elle avait joué c'était horrible ouais
mais pour elle puisqu'elle dans tout le
temps la même heure le soir il ya peu un
bon bain mesdames et messieurs merci
encore d'avoir suivi gens voient leurs
aises et on se retrouve tout de suite
merci matures